The joe rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
Do you sense a no nasal sort of a tone
voice today?
I tried to give you allergy medicine.
It's a little bit of a cold or allergies.
You think so?
Because you me and like everybody I
know exact same symptoms. Exactly.
Are you coughing? I'm mostly
sneezing, runny noses, burning.
I shit in my eyes and
I call once in a while.
No burning guys may just coughing
and limb running nose. Yeah,
but I don't feel bad. I feel physically
I feel fine. Maybe a little tired.
I think you're going to be okay.
We also podcast or rammed
all over your face today.
This week we've been
podcasting like crazy.
I don't know if that's
wears you out though. It,
it makes me run out of things
to talk about. Definitely. Yeah.
Like yesterday I had to try hard.
We did once after mine too.
We didn't doing, yeah, I've done
the naughty show and whatever. Yeah.
At least is a lot of people on those
shows that they can kind of keep the ball
rolling. Yeah, but you, yeah. Yeah.
You feel like you stuck? It's still,
it's still not laying on the couch crying.
I'm not used to doing that. Some people
out there working in coal mines, Brian,
I know there's real workout.
There's was real jobs.
Anyway, what I was about to say is
we're brought to you by a rubber vagina.
It's not rubber. It's like
a mineral. What does it,
he explained it yesterday.
I don't know, but he's,
he kind of hinted that I could maybe
put it in my mouth a little. Yeah,
he's think you wouldn't recommend it,
but I bet you could eat it and live
in his prime.
Steve in his prime would have eaten a
fleshlight or if you're a Tom and Jerry
deep, remember eating the shoes. I think
we talked about this a long ass time ago.
Remember? It was like big and
cartoons to always eat your shoes.
Like you cook it up and then you cut
it off like a steak. You know why?
I think we talked about it really.
Poor people used to actually eat
fucking shoes. Man. That's amazing.
Well,
you know,
I don't think we realize how bad it was
in like the Great Depression during the
Great Depression. When my grandma,
she's doing, my grandfather grew up,
he had this, this is my grandfather
always has had this serious,
serious air about him because he had
seen people that like almost starved to
death. You know what I mean? Like he had,
he had lived in an era where
that was a real possibility.
Like in America, you might
starve to death. It's not,
not going to be everybody,
but it's possible things.
Things were really fucking bad
and if you can live through that,
what does this have to do with plastic?
John is crime? Nothing. Nothing.
Goddamn and hand them back then.
Thank God we have them now.
Yes, first of all would certainly
keep the population down. Definitely.
This is an excellent tool for
population control. The flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and
are in the code name rogue and you save
yourself a bundle of cash. How much? 15%
get the fuck out of here. No, I won't.
I'm being serious.
15% enjoy it.
We are also sponsored by
onnit.com makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement
that I take, I take every day. Um,
there's a lot of information available
about it on [inaudible] Dot Com o. N n. I.
T if you fascinating to any of this stuff,
I you to please Google nootropics and Oh,
tropics and nootropics are essentially
nutrients that have been shown to have a
positive effect on the way your brain
works and Google it and read the pros and
cons and do your research
and experiment with stuff.
You don't have to go out
and just take Alpha brain.
If you have some experience in
nitro because you already know you,
you enjoy their effects, then go
ahead and try it. But you know,
if you don't try out some other
stuff first, try out some.
There's a bunch of different kinds of
nootropics that are available and it's all
available online through the wonders
of this thing called the Internet.
And it's not a check that,
and it's the Gabba is,
I'm completely different from a big top
puppet and I see it. Yeah, it's not yoga,
but Gabba Gabba just correct the
controversy. It's stews. Um, so anyway,
we have a bunch of different supplements,
a fitness supplements for a,
for exercise. There's shroom tech sport.
It's an amazing endurance supplement.
I use that when I do Jujitsu or kettle
bells or anything really difficult.
There's shroom tech immune, which is a,
a great immunity boosting supplement.
As I talked to you with a runny nose.
What we also have a new mood,
which is a, uh, um, a mood boosting
serotonin enhancing supplement.
It's called a,
it's a five HTP and l tryptofan.
And when you mix those two together,
both of them are responsible
for producing serotonin.
So it sort of a is like gives you the
building blocks for Serotonin and it makes
your brain produce it. It's nice,
it gives you a little, a little,
a little happy feeling. So it's
all natural stuff. Check it out.
The first 30 pills that you order,
it's, there's a 100 set, excuse me,
a 100% money back guarantee. You don't
have to return anything. You just say,
I don't like the stuff you
get all your money back. Okay.
We can't make it any easier.
We're trying to be as as fair
and as nice as possible. And our,
our goal always is number one is no one,
I don't ever want to do anything
where anybody feels ripped off.
So that's why we have this
money back guarantee in place.
I'm much more concerned with not having
people feel ripped off than I am with
making money. Okay, so there it is. Go
to [inaudible] dot com check it bitches.
O n n I t entering my last
name, which is Rogan, r o g,
a. N and save yourself 10% for now.
And for Ali. And what was the other?
He had some new fucking code
that gets you 35% Oh yeah. Shit.
I can't remember. He gets, you have to
download at yesterday's episode on Itunes.
Dammit. And he's in a plane right now
too. I can't even text him. All right.
Whatever.
Yeah,
you'll have to download yesterday's
cause there's a way to get 35% off. Yeah,
I'll tweet it. I'll tweet it. What it is
later. Sorry. Make him work for it, man.
It's me, man. I fucked up. I should,
I should've had that shit right.
It was something weird like
Tsk or something. Was it? Yeah.
And I ain't just making shit
up and confusing people.
Somebody probably had it.
It was on the tip of their tongue and
then you just said that and you just fuck
them sideways. Boom into the
woods. Speaking of fuck sideways.
We're talking to Matt Paxton from
fucking hoarders. Ladies and gentlemen.
Cue The music.
Let's start this officially
try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Yes,
no,
we are talking today to Matt Paxton from
hoarders and you want to talk about a
dude who has seen some unusual shit.
I've see it.
Everything must have a completely
different perspective on human beings than
your average person. Yeah.
Oh, I mean I'm, it's,
it's to a point now
where I have a hard time.
Like I mean I live in the suburbs now.
I have a wife and kids and I fight.
I'm bored to death like hanging out
with the guys in the neighborhood.
Cause I'm Amy during the day,
I'm, you know, shovel and
200 dead cats and you know,
45,000 pounds of Shit.
And then I got to go talk to some guy
about that email that he got in his cube,
you know, and I can't get, I mean
I, it's actually affecting, I'm,
I need the crazy shit down.
It's,
I'm really having a hard
time living a regular life.
So you will become addicted to all this.
Essentially. I'm, I'm a recovering addict.
My issue was gambling.
I had a serious gambling problem,
lost everything when I was 25
I mean literally rock bottom,
sitting in a ditch in Lake Tahoe,
Nevada.
I got my ass kicked by a bookie and like
had to start over like I literally five
bucks in my pocket and I went and gambled
it trying to make it 10 I hit rock
bottom and over the last,
what,
10 years slowly but surely got back out.
And I've seen it all.
And so it works for me with the hoarders
because like I'm not going to judge
them.
I've been in a much,
I mean I thought about sucking Dick
for money one night. I didn't do it,
but I put it on the table. Wow. Because
I was in a lot of trouble and I was like,
you know, it can't taste that bad.
It's not that horrible. You know?
Like I started justifying it in my head
and I put a lot of things on the table
that night. Wow. Sicker. And I talked
about it when we were like, you know,
I was like,
I'm going to run drugs from New York to
Miami just once and get out of trouble.
Not like I knew how to set that up or
anything, but in my mind I was like,
I'm going to do it. And so
like, I mean there was a lot of,
I was in so much trouble,
put a lot of things on the table.
So when I see a lady that's shit in
her oven, like I'm like, Eh, you know,
it's not that bad. Really. Oven. And I've
had one lady did. Yeah. She actually shit,
she shit in a bag and then put the bag
in the oven. Oh my God, to keep it fresh.
Right. What was this? Do you want to keep
it safe? Her Shit, she's saving her shit.
I get that. It was a special,
something that was a,
I think there was a birthday
cake and involved. Hey,
so we can't shit from a particular meal
that there might've, yeah, their moves.
Something important too. I know in, and
you know what? I'll get right at it.
These people are not crazy. I hate
that word. Crazy. They sure sound it,
but something really intense has happened
to them at some point in their life
that made him,
that got it.
Jump started it and got him and then
about 10 years of bad decisions got them
there after that.
But something horrible,
tragic happened to them that initiated it.
So there's this horrible tragic
thing that happened to them.
Does it just fuck with the
way they see reality? Totally.
I mean they're off sections of reality.
That's why I'm so excited to be on this
because you're willing to like go into
different realities and
understand that there are,
you could have a whole separate world
that exists in your mind even though
you're living in a different one. And what
happens is a lot of functional, crazy.
Yes, absolutely. Oh yeah.
We've had judges and lawyers and
doctors mean we had one lawyer.
That word when judge that we literally
had to clean his house from midnight to
6:00 AM because he didn't have
anybody to know what was going on.
But yet here I am. Hello
the guy on hoarders that 3
million people in the night,
see if I'm going into your house every
other hour is pretty obvious. You know,
we're cleaning up your house. What did
you have to do to the judge's house?
We'd clean it. I mean it was full. It
was coming. He but his was nice stuff.
It was like art and you know,
fancy things,
antiques and just things he had
bought who's just over Bali. He,
his was an issue with his wife,
believed stuff made you who you were.
And so he wasn't really, he
wasn't comfortable with, you know,
what you do as a person is who you are.
He was whatever you buy is who you are.
And so there they were searching for
more self worth and they just kept buying
things. Oh I see. And I mean we
get, it does, it's all mental.
It's never about the physical stuff,
which is hard to believe. I mean,
we could get deep into these hoarders
get into big deep worlds where they think
things matter. And I always
say it's called a, there's
an old Avett brothers song.
If you've heard David brothers.
Interesting band, really cool band.
How do you spell it? Even a v. E t. T
David brothers. They're, they're amazing.
They drive a lot of my theories
on life. Really? Yeah. Oh yeah.
I mean they changed the way I work. Like
first time I heard him I was like, wow,
this must have been what it must've been
like to hear the Beatles for the first
time. And I know that's a
road you don't throw out.
I know that this up from North Carolina,
they,
they've got, it's their bluegrass but they
think they're led Zepplin. Really? Yeah.
So they play really fucking hard core.
Some of that shit on. They, they just got,
they just got picked up by
Rick Ruben. Their last album
was Rick Rubin proof. Wow.
Does Rick Ruben some of that crazy beard?
I don't know.
I only know him from
like that Nyu picture.
I only know him from like Beastie boys.
Yes.
You think that was her freshman year of
college? Him and uh, who was that guy?
The black guy. Um, Russell Simmons and
him will roommates freshman year at Nyu.
Yeah. It's pretty crazy. It's crazy to
me. They both seem to be like really,
even though they're like super successful,
the both of you would be like really
nice guys. I met Russell Simmons, like,
you've his Twitter now about love.
It's all love and sexual yoga
and drink water. And it's like,
yeah, he's a big guy. I met him in
an elevator at a shoe convention.
Winning if there was a, there's a, what
is the name of the song? Brian? Uh,
10,000 words. Acoustic and it's probably
not something you went here. It'd be,
maybe it is to distraction. It is
there. That's in the back of there
trucks.
[inaudible]
hit that one line. Distraction four. Is
that a song that'll see you'll see them.
How they live is a really amazing one of
those dudes had his pants rolled up and
he was barefoot.
I fair country find that offensive.
They're definitely playing the
part in there. I mean they are.
I find that slightly offensive.
You knew they were filming that audio
dude decided to roll your pants up and
take your shoes off. There's still out
of your butt. No Man, I'm so comfortable.
They're still,
yes.
Yeah.
I was in love with the guy plays a banjo.
I wish that it wasn't enough to
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
it's a whole different world.
This is very original though.
It doesn't say,
I can't even think of things that,
it sounds like it's a six albums
in three years. Really? Yeah.
They just throw up music.
I'll have to check out.
But the whole point of that
was they have a line that says,
I'll never know silence without
mental violence. Whoa. And I get it.
I get really deep into the word and
then like I just love their music and he
said,
I never know.
Silence without mental violence and that
mental violence is the key word for me
for a hoarder there 24 seven they're
mind is never asleep like you and I,
you're a PR. I think your brain probably
goes over time a lot as I mean I listen,
I'm a huge fan of the podcast and it
is pretty up geeking out to be here but
like to to know out to have
you to thank you for sure.
So don't mean to like youth.
You're will you allow your brain to go
deeper than a lot of people that are
willing to,
I don't even know what that means.
All I do is if something is curious to me,
I follow up on my curiosity,
but you don't have the time to do it.
I think that's the difference. I'm not,
I don't work a regular day job where,
you know,
between nine to five I have to have the,
you don't allow rules to,
to limit your brain. Well I don't
have to, you know, it's really,
a lot of it is though I've,
I've been very lucky in and
how have sort of a managed to,
to manage my life and it's
just, yeah, I don't, I,
I can think about things. I don't
have to think about a company all day,
but someone does. Someone decide, oh
well you had a think of those things.
Your brain just goes, what while I'm
allowed to, I mean, I think that's
what's really hard for people's jobs.
It's really hard for people is, you know,
when you fucking work 40 hours a
week plus traveling, commuting,
that's a lot of time. That's not
yours. More than 50% your life,
not yours and your firm. For most of
us, W you know, not me, but you know,
I have been in the past for sure. We, you
know, when you work in a job like that,
you're giving away a giant chunk of
your life. That's the majority of us.
That's why the systems work. People are
tired. People are tired all the time.
That's why ridiculous systems are hard
to get out of place because people were
just too tired to fix them.
Yeah. I mean I'm lucky. I
always say hitting rock bottom.
For me it was like the greatest thing
ever because you fuck up so many times.
By the time you get back at a rock bottom,
like you pick, you pick yourself up,
you've broken all those rules and you're
like, fuck, I'm not getting a real job.
So you feel like you're
probably the perfect person
for this show because you're
not even judging these people cause hell
no. You've never, you've been done worse.
You've been down crazy street. Much
worse down. Yeah, absolutely. That's a,
that's beautiful man. Much worse.
And so I'm not going to judge this.
I'm totally not going to judge them.
No one is.
What a great message that is though.
If you're saying you've done much worse
and here you are with your shit together,
there's nothing. Yeah, but I sure didn't
for 15 years. That's so important.
I don't think I have my shit together now.
I'm just on TV and it looks
like I have my shit together.
I think right now you right now,
you do have your shit together.
If you're living in the moment right
now, we're seven yesterday. Yeah.
You're not mapped out, you know, shitting
your pants. You're not going crazy.
You know, you know he murdered a
hooker. No, but one of my guys,
one of my employees did murder other
guy have a lot. All my guys are ex con.
Oh yeah,
they're the best employees for this work.
One of your employees murdered again.
He did 20 years. He just hooker. No,
the other guy was a drug deal there. Any,
uh, I asked him, I was like, I was like,
what's a like you did 20 years? His
name's Ronnie, great guy. I was like,
what's the, I'm like, what happened? And
he goes, well, you know, it was me or him.
Like, okay, I get that concept. And
I go, so like tell me the story.
And I told him, I checked
with parole officer. It wasn't
a sec. I'm all my, I like,
I like my guys to be ex cons cause
they're not going to judge like,
oh cause they're gonna go back to jail
the next day. If they fuck up with us,
I'm their only chance. So with our
hoarders we're their only chance to clean.
So I prefer to have like part of what if
that one fuck up is like raping you or
hurting you? That would suck. I
mean, yeah. I mean I tend to, I,
it's never happened yet. I mean I, I
don't let them know my family if that,
if that's what you're leaning towards.
They don't know my family.
But you purposely hooked them
up with jobs. Absolutely.
I think they're the wounded. Absolutely.
And I know they're not, I mean a cow,
I'm a college kid drives me crazy cause
he wants to tech check a cell phone all
day. He wants to try to get laid that
and I don't me wrong, I get that too.
But I mean he, he's focused on everything
other than my client, my hoarder.
He's just happy to be. I'm receiving,
my worker is from prison is just,
he just got out on Saturday.
He's just happy to be out.
He's been in a 10 by 10 for 20 years.
How do you know whether or not you can
trust them and you pick I go through.
There's some, yeah, there's
some church groups that Rehab.
I'm in in prison and we know
they've been sober for two years.
These guys are like devoted to
a vegan diet. I mean they're,
they're already have committed
to lifestyles inside the
system to get clean. Wow.
So I mean try it.
I mean believe it or not,
staying sober in prison is
a really hard thing to do.
I sound you can get anything
you want, any water, anything.
These guys will tell you,
man, anything you want,
you can have it in a day if you're
willing to pay. Really? Yeah.
I mean these guards make 20 grand a year
and they can pick up an extra 60 or 70
running shit to the prisoners.
I don't really have a problem with them.
It's like I get it. It is what it is, man.
It is what it is. I get it. Know prison.
What's fucking, it sucks. It
sucks. I can't imagine it.
If you got to get high to get
through it, so be it. It's the worst.
It's the worst way to fix people. It's
the worst sort of friction. I mean,
it does for us, for some scares
them into a life of discipline.
Like Bernard Hopkins,
he's a perfect example.
You know Bernard Hopkins when he was
young. Yeah. Yeah. He, when he's like,
he's the current light heavyweight
champion and I think he's 47 he's insane.
Yeah, he's disciplined. It's
just ridiculous. And the
discipline is the key word.
I mean, these guys are so devoted,
they don't even try to eat it.
You think it's hard to eat a
healthy lifestyle outside of prison?
Try to eat a healthy lifestyle with
no, I mean they, they're just, I mean,
they'll leave like just water
and bread and that's it.
I mean like isn't unhealthy.
No. Well they'd, food is so bad.
Food is so bad and they'll
just so committed to a clean
lifestyle by the time we
get them. They're awesome.
It's so ridiculous to me.
The fact that we have private prisons,
that fact is so shocking to me that
there are actually businesses that profit
off substantially,
probably only profit,
a fair amount of people that get arrested.
And so they also lobby to keep certain
laws on the books to make sure there's
more things. So remember people for,
so there's more people in the prisons.
It's like this is the
matrix most that's insanity.
Most of my dudes are young black
men that never knew their dads.
They were just trying to get by.
They never had a fricken chance.
They knew they in their mind
selling a little weed on the corner.
That was right there.
Wasn't even wrong.
But I mean difference
between right and wrong.
It's totally subjective and a lot of
our guys, they don't, and their world,
they're just trying to alive.
Why is, why is that wrong?
But it's okay for the guy to
sell oxycodone because I'm white.
I didn't get caught or I had the,
I had the proceeds to not to get out
of trouble. Yeah, that's so silly.
So it's really predominantly,
so my guys, I like those guys.
They'll give me their heart
and they'll give my hoarder.
They'll give a hundred percent
effort well to my client.
And so that's the dude's I want. That's
really cool man. You know, look, I'm not,
I'm,
I'm certainly for prison.
I'm certainly for keep peak keeping
dangerous people. You raised a kid,
I hope you die in prison. I
agree. I agree. But you saw
we'd get out. Not just that,
there's a lot of other things that
happen that people get arrested for.
And I think,
you know,
I think we really could do with a better
way of rehabilitating people and a
better way of sort of managing
kids that are coming up.
We've got to recognize when there's big
populations of kids without fathers and,
and, and terrible neighborhoods where
everybody's stealing and it's just,
it's crime.
Everywhere we go.
There's gotta be a way that some asshole
can profit off helping these people.
But that's the only way I'm
pitching a deal right now.
Me and like I keep telling,
I'm trying to get, yeah,
cause to me it's workforce development
really. And if you do these kids, they,
none of them have dads.
Most of their dads are in prison or dead.
And I don't want to, I don't want to paint
a brush and say everyone is this way,
but a lot of these kids
don't stand a chance.
They just simply don't stand a chance.
So I'm saying they're going to be for
the next 20 years they're in prison.
So let's just go ahead and
get in there cause they don't,
I actually found out for something
like guys, you don't even qualify.
You think it's bad outside with no money
and no funding for social services.
You try to get funding inside a prison.
I mean they're at the bottom of the list.
There's no government money for prisoners.
So these dudes can't even check out a
book in the library until the last two
years of prison. Really. You own,
you're only available for educational
services your last two years.
So what if you're on, you're
on eight 20 years, 18 years.
You're sitting around Jurgen and
no books, nothing. Holy Shit, Ron,
he got worse from, he spent nine
years in solitary. Whoa. First,
first day went in, he had to beat
a guy up show that he was tough.
He got out and he was mad. He
said, I was angry for five years,
and think about that statement.
Angry for five years and you're in a 10
by 10 dark room and that's all that you
are, is angry. He had nothing else.
It's insane. So he, I mean nothing,
no break, nothing. Five years
he gets out, finds the same guy,
beats the shit out of God,
goes back in for,
for Jesus Christ because he was mad
at that guy for five years. Well,
he's fucking crazy at that point.
He was. Yeah. Wow. What is,
what is that experience like a locked
within origin contact for five years.
Nine he got out for 30 seconds
while we had a little contact.
If somebody came in for, I
dunno, 30 minutes. First of all,
have they ever let that guy out of jail,
Ronnie? He thinks served just time.
I mean, it's crazy. And that's another
part that's pretty crazy. You know,
he started his time,
you know,
one of a rehabilitation is that
there was no rehabilitation.
I'm doing it for your rotation.
I'm teaching them what
it's like to be a real man.
I'm teaching what it's like to to
talk and to listen and to communicate.
I mean we're doing the
rehab and that's what I'm,
I mean I really event my next
thing after the show's over,
I want to do a for profit program. When
we go into prisons in the last two years,
we give these kids an NBA cause
most of them are drug dealers.
They get cost of good sold. They get
business. I mean they were selling drugs.
They understand what things cost,
they understand margins,
they get it and they already
understood the principle of business.
They got two years to sit around
and do nothing. I want them to,
I want to teach them
good business principles,
let them let it be a contest and
whoever comes with a good idea,
we're going to fund them.
So when they get out,
we were going to have a for profit halfway
house that when they get out they now
get entrepreneurial training
for the next two years.
So they get out and they're in there with
us for two years and we train them and
then we teach them the business and get
their business started. That's awesome.
I think it'd be, I think there's a way,
but there's a way to make money on it too.
I'm not doing it for free.
I'm not trying to be,
and I'm not looking for government grants.
I'm going to take a piece of their
business and give him a chance.
And as long as there's a good business,
they're gonna make money.
Right.
You mentioned them two years to sit in
a room and think and get and be able to
put a business. I mean, think of all
the businesses you're putting together.
If you had no other
distractions for two years,
how awesome would that big and
that same prisons, awesome.
But to be able to be devoted to
something would be really cool.
Super motivating is what it is. He
can be. Yeah, it can be. Or it can be,
you know,
mortally depressing.
I mean we've got to figure
out a better way to fucking,
we got to get Halliburton involved
and rehabilitating cities.
Huge company have Halliburton
could get like a grant.
I mean they can to make
Detroit prior to rebuild Iraq.
Why can't we hire them to like,
you know, rebuild Compton,
why can't we hire them to like,
you know,
set up some salts and more community
centers where kids without fathers can be
mentored, you know, on a, on a,
on a daily basis so that someone can be
disciplined to put their life in a year.
I've learned with doing hoarders,
man, like I'm, I'm learning.
It's cool to make a difference. I didn't
know that. It feels good, doesn't it?
It's amazing. It's the new admits,
my new drug. I mean, it's the best.
I don't need to gamble more because I'm
helping people every day and it sounds
silly. It's like totally addictive to me.
I love and I'm needy. Don't get me wrong.
I need,
that's part of who I am.
I need that fixed every day of
someone saying you helped me.
But if it does for
greater good, fine. Yeah.
I mean what you're
getting your little rush,
but you're getting super positive people.
It's like you've changed something that's
just chaotic and crazy like gambling
into something where you're,
you're getting this rush off of only
positive things and things that benefit
other people. Yeah. That's
beautiful. That's like the
best still getting my rush.
I'm still getting my fix and
[inaudible] session three channels.
You figured out how to do it all and be,
everything's positive though.
If some child molester that
he has to have that rush to,
to do whatever you got to do,
what if you could channel that into,
he's got to have that rush and
he'll do anything to get that rush,
but that rush is now helping
people who they'll look.
That would be beautiful if I believe
that was true. That's a bad example.
I don't think that, I don't think
they, I think there's a, yeah,
there's such a high recidivism rate
or something wrong with their brains.
I won't even, I won't,
I mean I'll help anyone.
I mean looney Ronnie killed a dude
and I'm fine with Ronnie in my home,
but I'm not going to help a child
molester. I can't do it. Yeah, I agree.
I've met a few guys over the course of
my life who had killed people and you
know, some of them in war and some
of them, and that's all I knew.
Guys would kill people accidentally
and fights. I knew a guy I was,
that's actually, oh, he had a
weird look on his face, man.
I knew what God killed a guy, a buddy
of his and a drunk driving accident.
He always had a weird thing about him. You
know, while I was listening to your, um,
that podcast a couple weeks ago
when you were talking about you,
like you guys were talking about Rhode
Island and like all these dudes you were
talking about had gone to prison
or killed him on or, I mean,
they'd all guys had a couple of guys,
had this one guy be the
guy to death with a stick.
It was a comic more than a decision. I
mean, that's a commitment to, uh, to,
to an act. I mean, you don't, one
time you hit him and he dies, fine,
but you hit them a hundred times. You
know, there's, you made 99 more decisions,
crazy fuckers out there in this world.
It's amazing that you were like,
you're so
entrenched in them. Yeah. You seem like a
pretty, pretty together dude. I think so.
I mean, the kids changed me. I
mean, I got, I got two young,
I've got a two year old in a, in a five
month old and my wife changed me. I mean,
I never thought I'd get married. I mean,
I was living, when I got on hoarders,
I was living on a buddy's couch as
cleaning up shit for 12 bucks an hour.
Literally Shoveling Shit for 12 bucks
an hour and anybody who would hire me.
Okay. A dog, like people's
dogs, people's houses.
I'd go into a hoarder house
and clean up their shit.
[inaudible] an hour before the show even.
Yeah.
I was cleaning houses for four years.
I hit when I hit rock bottom. I mean,
I literally lost everything.
I was living on a buddy's couch for 200
bucks a month and I couldn't come up
with 200 bucks the third
month. He was like, dude, you
know, you're, we're 30 man.
Like you gotta you gotta do
something, man. I remember,
I'll never forget, I mean,
I've talked to some Alpine guys.
I, my 30th birthday I called,
I was engaged to another girl
and I realized I was like,
my life is a fucking joke. Like I
can't pull her into this. I'm not,
I got no business being married.
And so I called off the wedding like a
month before I was getting married and it
was, that was a hard decision. And I
was living on my buddy's couch and I,
it was my 30th birthday,
which is a milestone in your head.
And I said to my mom and my mom's like,
what do you want?
It's been a hell of a year.
And I was like,
I need a pair of running
shoes and I couldn't afford,
I was trying to run a marathon that year
and I couldn't affair for two pair of
shoes to run.
I didn't have no money.
I would like a hundred grand in credit
cards. And I mean, it was scary.
So I started cleaning up old ladies'
houses. Wow. And how'd you get that job?
Like how do I,
my dad died that the biggest thing,
important thing in my life for me with
my dad dying when I was 24 and that
changed my life and he, my
dad, I was a fucking asshole.
I was just a piece of shit.
All I cared about was drinking,
gambling and Nayland women. All three
great things. Don't get me wrong.
I mean my twenties were really fun.
It sounds like you had a good time and
and [inaudible] why'd you stop at a blast?
I really be talking to a guy who I spent
a good deal of my youth and pool halls.
Yeah. So you, I mean
hustle. I was a hustler man.
Attics on a regular basis if
you very, very common. Yeah.
I mean for me, I didn't, I hadn't
honed my hustle in the right place.
I'm still a hustler.
I'm just doing it on TV in a positive way.
I never changed my amp.
I'm just able,
I've learned I'm able to make more
money in a positive way than I am in a
negative way. How to put
on talk. Like I talk,
they don't say the things I say and
I've learned. Just being honest,
brutally honest is the
best hustle there is.
How did you get into this environment
where you're around like gamblers and how
did, how did all this
happen? Oh Man. I just,
I love at the first time I went to
casino I fell in love with it, man.
How old were you a college?
This Guy George. So that's
when you became a gamble.
Yanik towards Riyadh. This Guy
George Rome and he had Tourette's.
Really cool dude. He was a very
confident guy. He had Tourette's,
but he didn't give a shit. It's like your
problem that he had Tourette's. None is.
Wow. That's awesome. Very confident
guy. And so I was like very attracted.
I was like, man, this is a cool
fucking guy. Like he put it on you.
He did not care that he had Tourette's
and he would get the hottest chicks at
school. He's a really awesome, confident
guy. And I, my dad always told me,
he's like, you're never gonna
be the best looking guy.
You'll never be the hardest working guy.
You gotta be the most confident.
Cause it's like that's your only
in like you got no other value.
That thing broke you off.
No, he just was honest. He's like,
you know, you're not going to be rich.
You're not going to be rich. You're
not going to be back. Here's a rule.
You ain't got a big dig. It is
what it is. And my dad got it mad,
mad women. I mean he got, and
he was so ugly, but he just
loved him. He knew how to,
he talked,
honest.
He talked on us and he treated them like
be treated with respect and as a women.
And so I learned a lot from him.
But when my dad died,
I went to this little place
called comfort zone camp.
It's a camp for kids that have lost
their dads. And so I was in la,
we helped to build the La
camp and my wife and I did my,
but I met her there and uh, but we help
build these camps for these kids at all.
Their dads had Biden died and drive bys.
So you meet all these 12 year old
kids that are going in, you know,
they're getting recruited by gangs already
cause their dads have already there,
there 23 year old dads, you know, had
been killed 25 but we did. So we learned,
I mean I just, grief was a huge
part early on. And so for me,
like when I got out of my were like rock
bottom and I realize it's time to get
going where I've figured that out.
The,
the doing good versus doing
bad was at this camp. I would,
I got addicted to that camp.
I volunteered every single weekend and I
would just go away for three nights and
hang out these kids. And that's when
I got my new addiction was then wow.
It changed my life. That place
changed when I met my wife there.
I came up with new business, my business
clutter cleaner. I came up with it.
They're helping these kids. I met a lot
of great women and met my wife there,
so I mean I wouldn't have what I have.
How did you pull yourself
out of the gambling spiral?
You should. You found your,
I ran like a fucking chicken man.
I mean I got my ass kicked by a bookie
and I owed 40 grand the night before.
I had $10 left to my name. I knew I
owed this bookie when it was, I mean,
I think it was 40 grand and it was a lot.
I knew I only had $10 in my pocket
and my girlfriend was waiting for me.
I was in Lake Tahoe.
She was waiting for me at the top of the
hill up at heavenly and I was gambling
all night. I can't hide,
tend to what, $5? In my mind,
I thought I had $5 at the end
of the night and I was like,
I better put this down.
I got to get a cab ride home.
So I was giving up at $5 to my
name and I owed 42 the bookie foot.
Yeah. Which for a 24 year old kid and
make it not making that as a lot of money.
And so I put the chip down, lost,
came out, I had no, my last,
my last dollar came out and
had nothing and it was like,
I got a fucking problem and,
but I was looking at the cabby and he's
like the guy that drove me back every
night and he was like, he looked at
me and was like, I got no money man.
So I started walking up hill five miles
uphill to the ski resort. Tom's a very,
uh, awesome isolating place. So it
was a five mile. It's inclined roads.
We went up and I'm walking up this thing
and he came and picked me up and he's
like, dude, you gotta, you gotta
get your life together, man.
You got to quit gambling and everyone is,
and at that point I was still judging
people and I was like looking at this,
I was like, this poor stupid cab driver
knew God knows what happened to him,
but I was totally judging
him yet he's saving me,
he's picking me up and so I'm still
treating this guy like in my mind like a
piece of shit. And he picks me
up, he drops me off and I'm like,
can I give you anything I can, I eat.
He's like, dude, just stop gambling.
And he looked at me like, just fucking
stop. That's when they just stop. Well,
and I called my mom the next morning
and she was like, you're on your own.
So then I went, I called the bookie and
I was like, I don't know my dude, man,
I don't have the money. And I mean,
this was like a movie. He was like,
no worries man. Everything's going
to be fine. We'll work it out.
What do you have? And I was like, I might
be able to scrounge up $1,000. He goes,
no worries. Come on down. I'll meet
you down this afternoon. So I was like,
this isn't like moves at all. This is
great. This we're going to work it out.
And I went down, he took the thousand
bucks and he'd beat the shit out of me,
broke my nose. I totally was
just clueless. And he, he just,
he broke my nose and beat the shit
out of me. That was my rock bottom.
And I was like, what the fuck am
I going to do? So I called around,
I called an old boss and I told him
what had, my mom had already said,
you're on your own.
Find a legal way out.
And that was the night where I put a
lot of dumb shit on the board and I was
like, alright, I'll just be a prostitute
or I'll do whatever. Like I was like, Oh,
you know, I was like, I can be
mentally strong. I can figure this out.
And I was lying to myself saying,
I can figure this out. Wow.
And so ended up an old boss got
me a job in Chicago when he goes,
when can you get, this was a
Tuesday night. And he goes,
when can you get there?
And I was like, Friday.
He goes, you start Friday,
they're going to pay off the bookie,
but you're going to have to
work for a year to pay it.
They're going to take it out, peace
out every night. And I was like, great,
thank you. And I literally, my buddy,
I didn't have money to get home.
So I had to play poker that night.
Borrowed 50 bucks from my buddy and play
one enough money playing poker to get
gas money. Oh my God. And that's why I
drove home and I never gambled again.
Really? You just quit? I quit.
I ran away and I still run away.
I still run away to death.
I just don't get,
I mean like this is the worst week for me.
The first, uh, the NCAA tournament. Oh,
killing me. Killing me, man. Oh my God. I
love it. Do you still watch it? Oh yeah.
Love it. Oh Wow. No, I just don't do
the sheets. I delete all the emails.
I just can't do the
sheets. Wow, that's crazy.
So you just love that kind of limited in
every day. I, you know, I don't sort of,
well you have a handle on it. Yeah.
I mean I think gambling eight years,
I don't really, yeah, I'm lucky.
I mean my kids are just wearing me out
and I don't really have the effort for
that kind of stuff anymore.
Does it still draw you though?
Every once in a while I get that itch.
Yeah. Every once in a while I'll get that.
Like I had it this year.
I had a really bad itch and I had a
flight to Vegas to do a hoarder's episode
and it wasn't even in Vegas. I just had
a three hour layover and I was like,
fuck yeah,
I'm going downtown.
And I got excited and I hadn't had that
itch in a long time. Like I can drink,
I can smoke, I can do whatever,
cause I can walk away.
I can't walk away from a table. That's my
weekend. I don't know how to walk away.
I have a dollar or 10 grand fucking
your special brain chemistry,
whatever it is in your mind.
Me, that's my gambling comes up.
You just being love is because that's
my ultimate way of shoving it to the man
and like, I'm better than you. I can
do this and I'm going know it's for me.
It's a self worth thing. I was
looking for self worth. So again,
but how do you get so forth that it
began for me? That's where it went, man.
I mean for you you might get,
I mean where do you get yourself worth?
I don't know. I get it too. I
want to think about it. Yeah,
my new thing now it's like I really know
that I'm making a difference on these
podcasts, so I dig that.
I'm starting to get it.
That's where I'm putting my rough go.
Five decisions away,
five decisions away and when it is
essentially what does it well it's about,
it just recounts all my mistakes.
Over the last 15 years,
I was doing a hoarder's where a in New
York City where this guy had a mass,
he had an acre in Brooklyn,
a massive property in Brooklyn.
This guy inherited it
from his dad and it was,
had about six feet of bicycles
all the way through the yard.
So an acre at six feet high.
Think of the metal,
the value of that metal was probably a
hundred grand and metal and he had a bum
living in his yard.
So inside the hoard there was a bum living
there and that was one of the things
we had to clean up. We had to get
rid of the bum. So I was literally,
I mean this is two years ago,
I'm sitting here in uh,
in Brooklyn hanging out with this bum. His
name is Gregory. I'll never forget him.
And as a,
and this is the cool thing about hoarders,
I get to meet all dudes and I was
like, all right Greg, your head,
you end up here man. Cause he had, I
mean he had a bunch of like 40 ounces.
He had a bunch of a bunch of these magnum
condoms and so I was like, fuck yeah,
this guy's getting more acid than I am.
And he lives in, uh, in shack, you know,
speeding. And he was huffing.
I didn't realize it was hot.
He was just huffing gasoline huffing
gasoline. Yeah. Condoms. Yeah.
They would fill up the condoms
and then, uh, with the fumes.
And I thought he was getting asked. I
didn't really, I was just trying to get,
hi Joe. Hey. It is what it is, man.
Wasn't there a show on recently
where a woman had an addiction with,
with drinking gasoline? Yeah,
my strange addiction. Yeah.
What, what was that about?
You pretty much said it. She, she was
drinking. She really would just share.
They also asked for it.
She loved it.
There's people that do crazy things like
sleeping with hairdryers isn't really a
big, I've seen eating
glass. I read the other day,
my wife forwarded me this thing
apparently second to porn.
The most downloaded stuff is
I'm watching fat people on like,
people pay money to watch a fat
per stream, live a fat person.
Just living. Oh whoa. Second to porn. No,
I like the naked fast second
deport pay to watch face.
So there apparently is tons of website.
There was some girl on a, she was on TV,
my wife saw it.
There's like people out there that you
would pay like a monthly fee to just
stream live to watch this
fat person walk around. Wow.
And that doesn't do it for me,
but gambling did.
So to me I think it's all,
it's everything is related and the whole
reason I do well on hoarders is because
I've been lower or made worse
decisions they ever have.
And so they trust me and I am able to,
they know that and I screamed
that story to them. So before I,
by the time I get to meet with a hoarder,
I'm already part of their family because
they know I'm not about to judge them
period.
So you're just,
you're just helping them and
pulling all their junk out.
It's easy to throw shit stuff away now.
I also don't mind,
like I get the bad stuff so
I get like 200 dead cats.
Is that cash shit drive you crazy or,
I mean,
the urine is what gets me and I can't do
the year end. The shit you don't smell.
The urine is much stronger seeing that
actual dead cats. I mean, I hate cats.
I could get that.
I'm happy with the cats
and he's now dead dogs. I,
it's hard. I can't do that. The bumps you
out. Yeah, that has, I saw one with dog.
A blood lab was just laying in a cage,
dad. And that was really sad for me.
But like, I see a hundred
dead cats. I think it's funny.
Like that was really quite good. She
just watched it there. Yeah. Starvation.
It was really sad. Yeah. But it's weird.
Why is it any different for a dog
from a cat? It shouldn't, you know,
the diapers is my favorite now. I
laughed. I will fucking, I love, I mean,
I did one where this lady,
uh,
we had a really bad earthquake earlier
this year on the east coast and it's
right,
right near Washington DC and I was
literally filming a hoarder's episode.
I'm standing,
this lady's sitting on her toilet.
We're on the second floor of an old
brick townhouse outside of DC and a big
house and I'm standing on four feet of
her own diapers that she's been tossing
in a corner and her own diaper, own
diapers. So she take a shit in her diaper.
Oh my.
Or she'd have her period in her diaper
and it's just throw it in the corner and
the pile built up to be about four foot
high, about six foot across. Oh my God.
What are you dressed like? You and
the Hazmat suit? Yeah, that one.
I was in a hazmat suit
most of the times I tried,
I mean I just wear like boots and jeans
and a and how is she like existing in
that? They can live and they can live
anything. It's like an 80 year old smoker,
you know,
you see these guys and you're like,
you should be dead 20 years ago and he's
the toughest fucking guy you've ever
met.
Her immune system must be going to be
an all hazmat and then they're just
sitting there hanging out.
Oh my God. I don't like to,
if I'm conversing one on one with them,
I don't want to have a mask on
because I think that's a wall and I,
and I don't want to lose
that trust with them,
but sometimes I'm not going to kill
myself from smelling your shit stupid.
I don't,
this shit doesn't bother me.
It's the like when there's fleas that
have sat in your shit and then the fleet
comes up and sits on me.
That's when I got into,
I don't want to be like sleeves on
my face full of shit, not just shit.
Your shit is a crime. It's more personal
and I know it's yours. So anyway,
this lady, this was the crazy part,
this lady, this is the greatest. Yeah,
I ain't got to the good part yet.
Wait for it.
So then I'm talking to her about like,
tell me the first, I was like, I don't,
I understand how you, after 10 years
you can throw your diapers. That's easy.
I said,
but the first time you made the decision,
I'm not going to shit in the toilet. I'm
going to just throw this in the corner.
I was like,
the first time is the hard decision.
So like that's what I was trying to get
to her. What did you, what did you think?
Why were you thinking this is okay?
Where did you justify in your head
that this is an acceptable behavior?
And so it's,
that first decision was so important to
me and as I'm asking these questions,
the house starts to shake
sideways and I'm like, hmm,
maybe we just got hit by a truck.
And then all of a sudden the
house starts to shake up and down.
And finally there's a 300 pound
camera guy right behind me as well.
And all of a sudden I was
like, holy fuck, this must be,
I've never had earthquake before. I
was like, this must be an earthquake.
And the house is just, it's
like, so I mean it's like Julio,
I mean it's just a circle and I'm
like, Eddie Max Freak out. I'm like,
get the fuck out. I'm screaming.
I'm like, get out, get out.
And I run down the steps and
I look at it and I'm like,
I don't want to die under your shit.
That's the worst place
to die under your shit.
And I realized I'm screaming this at this
lady in front of 30 people and it was
worse for her than the damn earthquake.
Me telling her I don't want to die and
under her shit and I felt so bad and I
was like, I just almost died in African
house and I'm worried about, you know,
upsetting this lady. Right.
But like that was you.
You never know what you're going to hit.
I mean,
that's what I love about my job
also. I mean, you, you know,
knowing that just feel like
you've just crossed a line. I did.
I cross the line with her, an iPod. I
still buy judged or every time I talk to,
and you knew she was crazy going in
there to like to say you're crazy.
Once you're there, you don't say it. It's
not you. It's, it's obvious. It's like,
it's like telling a girl with
big tits that she has big tits.
Like you don't need to say it.
Everyone knows sometimes you
live in the real privately. Yeah.
So poker in the back and let her know
she's scared to let her know,
you know, don't try to keep
all your cards on the table.
Right.
Brian red band.
I often find that I think I'm a
hoarder and it's because it's uh,
I'm such a tech Dork that every one of
these things that you see here comes with
a cable and an instruction book and I
feel like I have to save that because I'm
going to need it later. That is
hoarding tendencies, believe it or not.
What's that?
Are we get guys that they want to
fix? I can fix this, I can fix this.
It's they hold on to things now
you actually know the limits.
Yeah,
I know the limits to a point,
but also that enclose or my
two horrible things. I just,
I hate fucking folding clothes are
hanging up clothes so I just kind of like
keep them in like, like piles
in my closet. Like it's pretty,
that's the two things.
I have a million Uber Douchey MMA tee
shirts that people have given me that I'll
never wear. It's like a battle
ax and to a skull, you know,
like chop your head,
you must get so much stuff from people
because you're like kind of one of the,
one of the original dude. It's cool.
In some ways I get, uh, you know,
people send me like cool equipment,
so it's good in that way.
I get cleaning supplies. I mean, nonstop.
People send me equipment they want me to
use in a house, you know? Well, I mean,
it's good to get that shit
for free, isn't it? Yeah.
I just give it to the order I don't need,
I'm a minimalist. I don't want anything.
How many people that you go in and sort
of intervene and restructured their
life? How many of them, how many
of them does it stick with this?
This is the number one question.
Um,
if they invest in the therapy and I say
invest, I don't mean money. I mean time.
If you invest fully in
the therapy process,
it's about 60% with my guys. 60%. Yeah.
If you don't do the therapy guaranteed
hundred percent failure. Wow.
It'll be full within two
months and usually faster now.
And I don't want to say
you said 60% success. Yeah,
but I don't want to say it's not always
traditional therapy. A lot of these,
when you see me on hoarders,
these are stage five hoarders,
which they're the worst. I mean,
they haven't, they've lived it,
been shitting in their living
room for 20 years. I mean,
I'm talking extreme extreme.
So traditional therapy is
not going to work with them.
So I don't want to act like if you
just talk therapy, he's not going to,
it's not for everybody. Right. And
so a lot of my stage five hoarders,
they've got to have,
there's a lot of new,
there's a lot of western therapy that's,
that's actually amazing.
And there's a lot of, um, uh,
post traumatic stress disorder,
a light therapies that we're doing with
a lot of that the guys are doing with
all the guys coming back from Iraq now.
Those are some really fun like
guys that are, it's this light
therapy that they,
they hit him with all these
light treatments and it
actually helps them remember
whatever that tragic event was,
whatever the trigger was.
And it helps him go back to that because
most of these like a hoarder. Oh,
like it sounds crazy. I think it's fair.
I'm not a doctor. I mean I'm a trash guy,
but like the therapist that we work with,
they brought, we brought in some new,
like how many,
what was it?
Homeopathic doctors that have come in and
we found that traditional medicine may
not always be right for hoarders.
And it's really interesting.
What does a homeopathic
doctor going to give?
Like is there something in there fucking
homeopathic book about hoarding? No,
I mean there's ginger root. Well Shit
like, I mean, like I acupuncture,
acupuncture does some crazy stuff,
man.
It doesn't at some bright
ideas fucking swears by,
it's all he talks about.
It's totally legit. Is it
legitimate? Is it one of those,
uh, power bracelet things where you,
well, if you believe in it, yeah, sure.
I know what you're saying.
I mean I had acupuncture done once
on an injury and a neck injury is,
I don't think it did shit well so for you
it's not legit, but I was open minded,
which just didn't work
for me at that moment.
Maybe it was something I needed
to do more than once or something.
And when Joe Diaz described that it seems
like he says Shit Weird Shit sometimes
like oh just brown shoes came out of my
foot. And I'm like, what's that mean?
She puts a foot and a bath and you see
the impurities come out of your body.
Like impurities are coming out of your
feet. Like what are you a fucking plan?
I've had brown shit. What'd he had
brown shit on my feet kind of out of it.
Makes Sense.
There's like a lot of like pseudo medicine
talk that these people throw around
and I always get confused.
I know I never know what's real
and what's just a crock of shit.
I'm old school man. If it works for
you and I believe it's with faith,
with Madison, whatever, if it
works, it works for you. Cool.
It may be totally fake in my world,
but in your world, if it works for you,
I'm fine with.
If you ever met one of those crazy dudes,
it's like a healer and says you can line
up your meridians and touching places.
I've seen,
I seen guys that have smart guys
convinced that they can actually do that.
Oh yeah.
I mean I've seen that with real like
real successful people and they'll start
telling you how great this guy is.
I'm telling you,
it doesn't make sense at this guy.
He's like a,
he's like some sort of a
[inaudible] or something.
He knows how to line up your Meridians
and you meet the guy and you know,
if you are like me, you probably have
a very highly two seconds on a boat.
Yeah. You're like fuck out of my flat.
At least you're still talking to Andy.
Dick. Dick is not full of shit. I'll tell
you that. Don't say that about it. No,
just kidding. That is one thing.
And I hope so. I love Andy.
He's definitely not full of shit
though in these, he's crazy,
but he's not full of shit. But,
um, yeah, that, uh, that this,
this guy was like doing all this to these,
uh,
these dudes that I knew that were
like, you know, successful dudes and a,
I had to come along and, and you know,
and meet this fellow and you know,
started asking him about the
science behind what he does.
And it's just the more you get
deep into questions with it,
the more it starts crumbling.
Like, where'd you learn this?
What does it never stopped
with the question? Oh, it
was just, it was ridiculous.
It was preposterous. Involved
Turquoise. And they also did the thing,
he did something,
I don't like the Chrysalis.
It's something that I
really don't like. He, um,
he reached over and like pinched a hold
of my trap muscle while we're talking.
You ever have a conversation with
someone and they're like holding onto,
you know, not, not
hard, like not to, yeah,
but it wasn't even to the point where it
wasn't, I wasn't, I was not insulted him.
So he might say, look, well I was, I
was like, it's about to get physical.
It was not that he was being very
friendly and like a friendly gesture,
but he almost like hug. It was a weird,
like he had like a light pinch on me.
It was like a light pinch. It
wasn't, it was just a little,
just something that made me think like,
why is he doing this?
Like ever talks about dude, you ever
talked to dude in the hold your knee.
They were lean in and they hold
your knee and then they, they,
they want to tell you and I'll
tell you what right now Matt,
I didn't know what I was
going to do. They're like,
why the fuck are you holding?
Yeah, they were diverting you from
whatever it was really enhances the most.
So the guy did that when
he was talking to me,
which automatically makes me feel
like he's a charlatan pickpockets,
if I know that this guy is,
it's a hustle is a mental hustle.
This is what he's doing.
I mean,
obviously he's a tricking these people
in the fixing that he's healing and more
maybe as magic leave that on the table.
But when a guy does like a psychological
move like that where he just reached,
I mean that's like, that's really
like, it's like really base. It's not,
that's not like complicated at all.
It's like really obvious.
Like if somebody reaches in and
holds onto you, it's an odd move.
Like why are they hoarders
at one at a bad moment?
I make sure I got a hand on her back
as a hug. Oh, you purpose, purpose.
But that strategy of good energy,
that's still the same thing for
negative energy. Well, it wasn't even,
this dude wasn't even being negative.
He was just,
he was going to make me uncomfortable and
I was just going to go along with what
he was saying. You know, he didn't think
that that's, I think that's what they do.
Then you'll like really good conmen
will make you uncomfortable and all of a
sudden you're going along
with what they're saying.
Then you start justifying your
actions and then you're a part of it.
And you start telling everybody, I'll
tell me, and he's great at what he does.
Yeah, well this guy wasn't
bad at it. Yeah, he just
wasn't standup comedian ready.
You know, stand up. I'm going to,
I'm going to stand up comedian
for training for three years.
If you're full of Shit, I'm going to
look at you immediately and go, oh,
look at this guy. It's very rare.
Unless someone's like a real sociopath.
It's very rare that I don't think
something's wrong. I immediately,
socially and even the sociopath,
they can't.
There's a natural way of interacting
with people that some people just don't
possess. They don't possess that
because they're fucking crazy.
And you can tell pretty quickly when
you're talking to someone and whether or
not they'd have her hat,
but how disturbing is it when you have
friends that don't see that and then what
your friendships,
but it's not even that they're bad people.
Just that like you knucklehead,
you're in a cult.
Do you understand you were in a car
and get that with the dam? Amway man,
I get so upset when I find out a
true friend is like selling Amway.
All of a sudden I don't,
I don't even know pyramid scheme.
Is it like you're a good friend?
Like I trust you,
you're a good friend and here you
are trying to sell me on site.
Like and I realized it's not that they,
they were sold. I mean they're totally
blind to this right now and I'm like,
oh my God, like you fell for this.
Like I feel really bad and then it,
but it does make me reevaluate
my friendship with this person.
I've had to talk John half run
on a four or five different
pyramid schemes.
John Heifer,
I will call you every other
month with some new new thing.
Well all I have to do is invest 20,000
and this is what other guys have gotten
out of this.
It's yellow Windex.
He always has some new
things I was going to train.
I'm going to train the businesses how
to write jokes and they're going to make
their own advertisement and I'm
going to do it all in house.
He's always got these wacky
ideas he's doing. You know,
he's doing a lot of these shows where he
does conference calls. Well he doesn't,
we haven't done a podcast
and I don't know, months. And
then I asked him recently,
he's like, yeah, I'm on the
road for 17 weeks. And I'm like,
are you fuck he's on the
road 17 weeks in a row?
I probably a day maybe if at all.
Wow. Have runs in their animal.
Who's a road animal?
Have you had an episode that,
that you couldn't show for whatever
reason? Like was there an evidence scene,
a body or,
yeah, we get a lot of crime scenes
situations like you will, I mean,
I personally have not on the show. I
mean, privately we found a lot, right? Um,
one of the other guys on there,
he had one the other day
that this guy Cory traumas,
who's also on hoarders and he went into,
her job was cleaning the house and they
found the lady's husband wrapped up in
a, he'd been dead for like
five years. And you, oh my,
she just didn't get around
to calling the cops.
But in her mind then for an a
hoarder's mind, that makes total sense.
Tomorrow I'm going to call tomorrow,
I'm going to do this. Yeah.
And I talked about that mental violence
earlier. It's that mental violence,
there's so much going on in their head
that they can't, you know, I had a lady,
she, she told me, he was like,
her mind is a massive spreadsheet,
excel spreadsheet and issues.
It's as many as many columns,
as many roses it can go. And she goes,
it's not that I can't let go of something.
She would have to check it off.
And she starts back up at one.
So the problem is she might get through
a thousand things in one day and only
600 of them got checked off.
And this is all in her mind.
But when she wakes up the next morning,
she's got to start back at number one
and she's added another 5,000 things on
the bottom, especially on her mind, is
working that hard. So for this lady,
that fan, you know her, her husband died,
she wrapped him in a damn shower curtain
and she's like, okay, I'll do it.
I better call Jesus Christ. I'm
going to call it. And I'm not,
this is not bullshit.
Like this is real life guys.
Like this is what happens
in a hoarder's mind.
And you don't see it in a half hour
show. Like, Oh this is why I'm so,
I think it's fascinating
for flame.
Fucking crazy probably is the town
that most people are fucking crazy.
They're not crying. I
hate that word. Crazy.
They're not crazy quick mental
discipline to set me up.
Yeah, they're fucking
crazy. You just said it.
Don't say that there's anything wrong
with being crazy. Cause I'm crazy Brian.
Fuck,
we're all fuck a little crazy.
And that's one of the parents I
found one that I like is crazy.
Every single person that I like is crazy.
They're crazy.
And if you're not look
crazy, you haven't anything,
you're boring. And I have
no value. This isn't crazy.
Tried to tell me Dunkin isn't crazy.
Tried to tell me you're not crazy
bitch because you guys know you're
37 years old.
You've got a clock that makes cat noises.
I did see it. Yeah. He's got a gun.
There's 50 cats in front of the
front of the logo. Is a cat here.
One of the old,
the old hoarders joke is,
I hate cats so much I won't eat pussy
anymore. Oh, you just get so sick of it.
You just haven't had a good cat full.
Why do you a hit cancel much?
What does this now man,
the smell just, well,
you're seeing the worst case scenarios.
You know what I mean? Cat In my house,
my cat's nice. Cats exemplify for a
hoarder. They exemplify easy love,
easiest way to get love.
It's easy to investing in a human
relationship and a cat is a survivor.
Like cats will scrap to any level.
Like they will not die like had to die
naturally like a human couldn't live
other cat. Absolutely. The minute a cat
dies, the other guy going to eat you.
Totally.
So we'll find like a bunch of,
like their eyes are eating out and test
it thoroughly. Now cats are scrapped, man.
It just try it. Oh my God. So that's
like code changes it for you. Yeah.
We had an animal expert telling
me one time, she's like,
you know when a cat's up there looking
at your face when you're asleep,
it's weight. It's, it's literally
waiting for your last breath. That's not,
it doesn't love you.
It's not there to hang out with you.
It's there to fucking kill you.
How many people get eaten by the cats
after they die? I'm sure there's,
I'm sure there's a bunch. I don't
know. I bet it is pretty common, right?
Someone look, I also though dogs do
that as well. The people when they die.
Absolutely. If a dog's left in a
apartment by with only you to eat,
they're going to eat you. He goes back to,
it goes back to my boy, Ronnie. I mean,
you got to do what you gotta do to
survive. Cats are gonna do the same thing.
Animals will do it. So are people, man,
you got to do what you gotta do and
when you're pushed to that limit,
you got to do what you gotta
remind me not to Piss that guy off.
People stays in solitary for five years.
Thinking about kicking a dude's. I did a,
I did stern the other day and he was
like, man, you must be really tough guy.
And I was like, nope, my guys are. I'm
not, was like, I've never thrown a fit.
I've never thrown a punch in my life,
but I don't have to because I guess I'm
really tough dude behind me. You know,
if you're a Douche bag,
most of the time you never going to have
to hit anybody if you're not a Douche
bag, rather I, you know, at
one time, like a nice person.
How often does it really going to come
up? I don't think. I mean, I hope never.
Yeah, most likely. I mean, someone else's.
My wife's gonna fucking hit
me before someone else gets
a chance. Does she throw?
She would. Yeah. She's a tough
girl. She's a very tough,
now you were in the ditch. He got beat
up by this fucking guy and that was,
how do you go from that to cleaning?
Crazy. Beautiful. You'll laugh from me.
I actually, I wanted to,
I really enjoy old people.
I think their stories are fascinating and
so I actually wanted to start a senior
relocation business, which is moving old
ladies and I was like, that'd be neat.
You get to sit down with them, sort
through this stuff here. They're old,
hear their stories and it was it for me.
It was the great, Whoa, whoa. You like,
you were like seeking out
the stories of old ladies.
They're fascinating old ladies that like
their husbands have died in the war and
they never got remarried.
They have all this cool shit.
Their stories are fascinating.
Like amazing.
I was thought that'd be a cool podcast
just to have one old lady from a
neighborhood each week to just
come in a depressed. The fucking,
I like this one lady when they
dentistry from me, I was talking,
I was helping her clean her garage out
and her husband had died and we were in,
he had just died of Alzheimer's.
It was really sad.
And we started talking and I realized
she had a tattoo on her wrist,
some numbers. And I was
like, Yep. And I was like,
do you mind me asking about
that? And she's like, oh sure.
And she starts talking and she
clearly describes the dude.
I mean her husband or
her father is ironic.
Her father and her brother died
in the concentration camps,
but she met her husband there in a
concentration camp. They get to America,
they refine each other in America.
They have 50 years together, all that.
He died of Alzheimer's and she
said, I can still, I, she goes,
I could pick out the guy,
the u s soldier that opened a door to our,
to whatever, you know the
box they were in. She goes,
I can see the day we were saved.
And she,
and it was about a 30 minute story
explaining this guy and she's,
the minute that I realized we were free
and like those stories to me are fucking
amazing. Right. Amazing.
And then she was upset because her husband
died from Alzheimer's and she's like,
I mean it's 80 year old lady basically
saying to me, fuck Alzheimer's.
I mean we beat, we beat
Hitler, we beat everything.
And now this damned disease,
it takes my husband.
And it was a very honest and very just
fascinating moment. And so for me,
like I love shit like that.
And so that's why I wanted
to hang out with old ladies.
Like I'm net my generation,
I ain't going have anything like that man.
Like that's, I mean she saw
cars, she saw like, you know,
I mean, yeah, she taught me anything.
She was, if you ask, they will talk,
but they're not gonna. They're not
pretentious like us. They're just,
they're not going to tell you
shit if you ask, they will answer.
So when did you get into this hobby
of talking to old ladies about?
Always it always kind of trippy grandma.
My grandpa always got, I mean, makes
sense. I think they're fascinating.
I think it's interesting and I'm not
a big reader. I like to do lists.
I'm a listener. That's why probably are
so good for me. I love listening to stuff.
I love fascinating stories. And I lived
actually the first year out of college,
I lived in my mom.
My mom moved to England,
so I lived in her apartment and
it was in a retirement community.
So my first year out of college,
I was the only dude under like 60 didn't
even try to bang you. One guy did a guy,
Dick Kidding,
how much did you pay 100 bucks
now it was uh, you know,
so you went from that why?
When I tried it and the thing was,
yeah, in my town there was an old,
there was a business.
It was very,
very good at senior relocation
and I could never beat them.
I couldn't compete against them. So for
me it was a totally a business decision.
I went to this competitor and I
said, what do you not do? She goes,
we won't clean the messy ones. And I was
like, well, that's what I'm going to do.
Whoa. And so it was strictly, I
couldn't beat this woman in business,
the lady that owned the bigger company.
So I had to just do what didn't do.
Wow. How clever you are you. That's a
pragmatic dude. My grandpa was always,
he just said,
you find out what no one wants to do and
then do that and they'll pay you a lot
of money.
Grandfather and your father school
fucking great. And it was great advice,
but they were, listen kid,
you're not good looking.
You fucking do what nobody
else is willing to do.
I'm glad I found that out at 14 and not
at 44 I know, but it's so fun. It's good.
It's kind of broken to say to
your son, like, loosen my jeans,
Suck Soda, Yours. Pretty much.
Pretty much room. It is what it is.
Let's move on.
Get on strategy on what you can do.
So do you have a lot of self
confidence issues because of this?
Now I'm very confident.
Yeah.
He was telling earlier that's his dad
will know about your looks. You're not.
If you're interested in my look,
totally missed the point. Like
I'm not, I'm not handsome. I'm
see. Looks. Yeah, that right there
you, you said you're not handsome.
Why don't you think you're a very
handsome man. He's not a bad looking dude,
but I think not freakishly
ugly. You look clean, cut
personality and don't be
freakishly ugly. Yeah. I never,
I did fine.
I'd never gone without a nice looking
woman and they would never attracted to my
looks. They were attracted to my
confidence in what I do. What I,
what I actually do for people. Tom
Cruise movie, he could be in Magnolia.
They can give you like one
of the guys that created,
I don't know how tall Tom Cruise,
but I hear that I'm like five foot
two so he might be bigger than that.
Let me tell you, you're a lot fucking
bigger than I thought you're going to be.
Okay.
That sounds weird.
Now
he's got so excited seeing
the like girth to that.
Um, yeah. I was really
excited to talk to you, man.
For sure. This is you. I mean this is
the kind of stuff you wanted to, I mean,
I hope I get blown away.
Pass for sure.
I'm,
I love the stories of people feeling
that they're going crazy and then pulling
themselves out. I've, I've been really
lucky with my addictions in the past,
but I certainly know that I'm susceptible.
That's why I stay away from video
games. I've never really gambled. Yeah.
The only thing I've ever gambled on was
playing pool and I was never good enough
to win any money or to be like
a threat, you know, like it was,
it was a bull horn guys are dangerous. Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah. But I knew like what,
what I'm saying is I knew
what I was capable of,
so I don't have a big
enough ego to get roped in.
One of the ways that guys
get roped in his, uh,
you'll play a guy and he'll barely lose
to you and then they'll start trying to
raise the stakes or he'll barely
beat you and you think that he,
you think you're away,
you're a hat and you think you can get
back at them and then see drags you into
this deep water.
And then all of a sudden he starts
running out and then he starts playing
perfect pooling. You're like, what the
fuck? Just, Oh, you just got hustled.
He pretended to be a certain level and
really he was much better than that.
I was always, I'm sorry, what was, I was
always real aware that I wasn't that good,
so you couldn't do that to me and I knew
exactly how good I was at all times.
It's like your bullshit detector is
greater than your urge to gamble.
Well yeah,
yeah.
Got A, you've got a bigger high
off of calling that guy out
then you did off of beating
them. Well, you know,
not even just calling them out
and just being aware of it,
someone's busting moves. Yeah. You
know, being aware that there's some,
some fuckery is going down.
Yeah. But that's, I go
back to the self worth.
Like I think everything in life
is about trying to get self worth,
trying to get attention and like, what
am I, me, me, me, me, me. And so for you,
you got more credit in your own head for
calling that guy out and figuring out
the situation then you would
have for beating them? Probably.
I never thought of it that way.
I always just thought of it as like a
natural survival instinct. I mean it's,
you know, like you could,
you could, I mean like in a
fight, I always say there's a,
there's a, it's one thing to quit and it's
another teacher to strategically stop.
If I'm fighting one of your buddies,
you know, that's not quitting.
That's strategically stopping. I know I'm
going to die if I die, if I don't stop,
if I just run away.
Well,
the idea of saying don't quit.
It's really stupid because that means
so one guy is going to probably beat the
other guy that death. This is
not really necessary. I mean,
how mad are you at somebody?
I mean,
I can understand what I was trying to
kill you and you're using self defense
using martial arts when you beat someone
to death. I understand that. I am, uh,
some guy tried to rob you and he pulls a
knife on you and you get the knife away
from that guy and you beat him to death.
I'm with you.
I'm on your side 100% but
that's not what you want to do.
Most of the time you get in a fight
with someone, they just mad, you know,
they don't want to beat anybody.
Never that guy you're beaten up.
So there's a good time to,
there's a good time to stop and
say you're sorry and want to do.
It's fucking pounding on you. And that
guy should let you go and you should,
you should say you're sorry.
And that guy should let you go and
everybody should be cool about it.
And that's how it should go down. You
know, that's the correct way is to quit.
To me, it's always a
balance of like, how do you,
how do you get that self worth that you
give yourself credit for it and then you
move on and, and, and, and I just don't
get into arguments where you're right,
but the other guy can kick your ass.
Yeah, no, dude, you're totally right.
Don't get in those audience bad.
That's not,
especially if you think of like
a physical, but, uh, I dunno,
human conflict, man. It would be,
it'd be a lot better if most people
knew how to fight. It's like,
I feel I'm not a big fan of gun control.
And I feel,
especially in this day and age,
that there are so many guns out there
that for you to try to say that guns
shouldn't be available for
civilians to me seems preposterous.
It seems to me that,
you know,
you can't control the population
and periods of civil unrest.
We know that's true.
We know that you, you,
you're saying that a family should be
completely vulnerable and in cases where
were things go terribly wrong when home
invasions and things along those lines.
Fuck you. That's ridiculous. I'm not
a big fan of that. But you personally,
do you have guns? Yes. Yes, I have
cousins. Yeah. Um, but it, you know,
I'm also not a fan of shooting people.
You know,
I don't think you should go around
killing people if you don't have to,
but you know,
someone stepping in to tell you that you
shouldn't have guns and you shouldn't
be able to protect yourself.
Yeah. It's the thing,
and you can take that across
anywhere. Yeah, for sure.
I don't want to have an abortion,
but I don't want to not have
the right to either. Exactly.
Well and I didn't get into that.
Yeah.
In preggers it's since been a first
frustrating how we got on the subject.
W W w when got on the subject of guns.
It's just,
it's a passionate issue. Yeah. I
try not to get personal pretty ever.
It's not even a politics thing.
To me it's a personal liberty.
I am not a fan of anyone coming
along and telling you what to do.
As long as what you're doing is not
hurting me and not fucking up the
environment, you know, polluting the
world. You know, killing puppies. Go,
go have fun.
That comes up in hoarding a lot. They're
like, just leave me alone. I'm happy.
Well just let me be what happened to
chuck and diapers and I'm like, yeah,
but I'm like, you live in, I just
took 45,000 pounds of shit out of you.
Your House, your own shit. Like the way
it like that. Do you put it by the doctor?
Yeah.
By the time it's by the dumpsters.
You really pull off 45,000 pounds
of fuel. Shit. Only 20 tons. I mean,
that's a wow.
That's like 1000 pounds.
That doesn't even make sense to me.
I'm not even registering that
three of these rooms
full like to the roof.
It's a lot of shit that, I mean,
think how big your shit is. Oh Man.
How much of that would it take?
2000 pounds. I mean, it's coming.
I always say it's commitment.
It's Ted Smell for the neighborhood.
It's a very use Mallon.
I mean it's a very citrusy,
it's very orange, orange, chocolate,
orange orchard in his yard.
It's very citrusy.
Orange chocolate milk coming. Acid
breaks down to be more orangy Chocolatey.
That's crazy. For real or
not. If I go with yes there,
so it doesn't even smell
bad. I'm not, to me
I, the urine is what throws me off. A
urine would just fucking kill anything.
Bird shit is the worst.
You're eight and they don't actually,
she's not actually shit. It's like an
acid. It's called your rate, your rate.
I had a lady that did, uh, she
was a parrot hoarder. Oh God.
And that was disgusting.
Oh my God.
A pair of Warner
brothers movie. Oh Man. I, I've
seen it all man.
Like this was a great story cause she had
like 80 and she had 86 birds and I had
to take him,
I had to transport him to a hotel for the
vet to look at them. And so these are,
I mean this is her life,
right? Fascinating woman. Like
we thought she was a bitch.
Like she was just so angry and she loved
these birds and to point her husband
was in a wheelchair and he couldn't, he
was ready to come home from the hospital,
but he couldn't come to the home
because of all the stuff we were like,
what a bitch, you know,
like what a horrible person.
And so the first night we transport all
the birds to the hotel and I'm driving a
you on every other driving
a u haul through Seattle.
Like this is two years ago.
I mean,
I just,
and I was still making 12 bucks an hour
cleaning up shit at home and I'm like,
I mean, I was like, I would, I think
I did it for 500 bucks the whole show,
like a whole episode. And I was like,
500 bucks is more than I've made in a,
in a year, you know, so, so excited.
Driving a u haul with 86 birds,
I get to the vet and I only have
84 birds to who died in transport.
Oh, she's, and this lady,
this is her life right later we
found that as we clean more, more,
she refused to talk to me. We have
a therapist on set always, uh, to,
to make sure that their mental health is
just as strong as her physical health.
And the more the therapist and
I start talking, I was like,
I don't think she likes men,
period.
And the more if out it turns
out her husband beat the
shit out of her and that's
why she had built this wall. She didn't
want to clean the house out. So he didn't,
he would say back from the hospital,
she didn't want,
she didn't want to come in because
he's going to be shit out of her again.
And so we were like, oh we're
done. So we didn't clean the house.
We left it messy for
because it at that point,
the worst thing we can do
for cleaning house right.
And we really slowed down drastically.
We just cleaned the garage cause I don't
want to get them in the house. Bummer.
When you see people completely fucked up,
it's,
I mean it does make you feel
better about your own life.
I'll say that you realize and that's why
people watch our show. It may mean it's,
well people watch your show for
the water cooler talk. Oh it, yeah.
Did you fucking see the cats for it?
When you hear it?
About 45,000 pounds of Shit.
Do you actually show the shit?
You show me how you see me picking it up.
Bac me Shoveling,
shoveling human should the dead cats is
one thing that you very rarely see human
shit on TV that they'll show. I mean
they'll show it smeared against the wall.
There's one shot of me on the
Internet where I'm living.
I'm just sitting there like pointing at
a diaper and there's shit smeared all
behind the wall behind me and I was like,
wow, I can't make me put that on there.
People posted all over Facebook and
everything. Well you guys are in a and e,
right?
Rainy nights at nine.
It's cable and cables not
subject to FCC regulations.
A lot of people don't know that.
That's why shows like the shield got away
with being so crazy. I was like shit.
And Louis Louis CK show though
it gets away with being so crazy.
They're not really, um, it's,
people think that only like HBO is a
lot of swear really cables labs where
they're not really regulated by the
FCC because they're a pay service.
We edit out a lot on orders.
Obviously.
There's a lot of stuff we just
don't show that. I'm sure.
Would you like to show it? Yeah,
I leave me. If it was my show,
I would change it up a little bit.
I like what I would get more into the sh.
I mean I would get into the like
instead of showing up before and after,
I would put a half hour on the decision
to shit, you're going to our show,
like let's really dig into,
well how bad is your life?
I don't sugar coat that you got raped
by your uncle. Like just fucking say it.
Like I didn't know how bad physical and
sexual abuses in this country. Like it's,
it's ramp,
it's still me and I had no idea and like,
like let's get into it and
like, let's not, I mean we,
we shot what was the cause of all this?
A lot of time if you see shit on the wall,
they got raped as a kid. I mean like,
it's awful. Like now walk in the
house, I'll be like, Oh, who raped you?
Your uncle or your dad? Well I did
that one time and that he's like, oh,
it was my uncle had, you know, and I was
like, oh fuck. That's real. Like wow.
It was a joke on me as a bad joke,
but it was a joke.
That's how you crack jokes
and we go over people's house.
[inaudible] you're always taking
a leap of faith of the rape joke.
But I've found out that's going to be
someone's signature on a message board.
Oh God. I'm always embarrassed when
they post that stuff cause ain't,
he doesn't listen to the podcast
and said like, I'll get it.
Someone will post that, you know, they'll
post always take a leap of faith on
a raped him,
listen to the park on ABC.
You just don't give a shit. I'll give
it 100% I don't give a fuck sauce.
That's his point on Miami. You
know, if he, if you don't know,
you get involved with I'm a good person
but I'm honest. Well that's, I mean,
I mean I don't hold it back a brutally
honest. I am there to help him.
I will do it in a different style.
Yeah.
I mean I will always be able
to say whatever you want
and your message board on
a blog, on a video and then police it
a little bit. But they're pretty good.
They're pretty used to me.
Well you,
your story just so fascinating and he no
one should put any restrictions on you.
You have your best intentions in mind.
Oh, I ended up my day. I'm gonna help you.
I want to help someone, period.
But when you hear like God,
like you talk about how there was one
point in time you're thinking about
sucking a Dick for money. I mean, that's
of course not. Of course you're not.
And it's important when important,
when someone meets a guy like you and sees
you got your shit together, it's, it's,
that's a good lesson for someone to learn.
My wife doesn't love that story. I bet.
I bet she doesn't man. But she does
it. But Hey, I mean, it's reality.
It doesn't make you gay means
you were fucking Desperado.
And I think once you suck a
dick that makes you, for sure.
Yes. At one time. I mean,
if a guy sucks your Dick, I um, yeah.
You think so? There was a guy that came
back from my run. I mean, I've had a lot,
I've had some women that were
pretty awful. It's like my day.
They were like manly, just
gross, disgusting, disgusting.
But there's still feminine. They
still had double x chromosome. Yeah,
but that's it. That's it. That's all.
I mean technically they were
so you're not proud of that.
You would be more proud of that
then a guy sucking your dick or no,
I mean he knew Dick sucked is
getting your dig socks. I mean,
I'm not worried about case.
I'm never worried about the quality of
the Dick Sucking when it does happen.
Now I could give a shit.
I'm very concerned with the quality.
There's nothing worse than a horrible,
horrendous,
horrendous blow job was a terrible thing.
No one should have to get self.
Well I did have one bad one.
How could you not have one battle at
one bad one and she was like a life that
you live in and she thought it was like
she thought I man, not as good as that.
You haven't had one crazy blow. At
least one shitty ones. She was like,
she thought she was great.
Like clearly people told her she was
wonderful and it was clearly not.
What was she doing was like too much
biding and too much. Too much teeth.
Ooh, likes teeth. Is there a guy
out there that you to mother's Day,
but the second I feel team game over.
I always say if you,
if you're thinking teeth,
thank finger in the ass hole,
it's easy fingernail in the assholes.
Yeah. When you go to your house,
is your house super? Trust me on
that. Yeah. Say that again. Don't.
If you go out there and you're gonna set
some guy's dick talking to the ladies.
Ladies, don't bite it. Don't buy it.
It just play with his asshole instead
play with his asshole and stuff.
You'll be much fairer fingernails
and giving advice to the lady.
That's what you like.
If you're giving me a blow
job, but you're not. Wow.
This is amazing. Now you know, now
you know I'm homeboys honestly.
So when you go your handy right now,
the fucking sports are lighting up.
Do you know that Mac passing,
he's asking people to a
point where there's one hole.
Do you know that he represents your
network? Do you know that, hey,
I bet you 18 of the 24 would
prefer the 1824 the agents.
Is that the good age demo for apparently
and 18 to 49 is where the money is,
right? It's male. 18 to 49 they
spend the most money, you know,
spends the most money. Gay dudes, most of
them don't have kids. Dinks dual income.
No kids, cause we call dual
income. No kids, ton of mine,
man and marketing. That's what
we called. Are you allowed to be?
That's not a derogatory mark. That date
back two gay guys feel uncomfortable,
but that dank sounds like you guys don't
care. It sounds like a time. Hey guys,
hey give a shit about the rest
of the world. Gay guys are happy.
They're enjoying their life.
They don't care about anyone else.
That's a big generalization.
I bet a lot of gay guys with a gun in
their mouth right now that disagree with
you.
I actually had a lot of buddies that are
gay and they don't have time to think
about it. They just out sucking Dick.
They're fucking apartment all day.
When you go to your house
is your house like spotless?
Like do you own a spoon that's in a
glass case and like everybody added and
sanitizers on every
wall? We, I was, we were,
my wife and I were extremely just
anal retentive and then we have,
we've too young,
we have a two year old and a five month
old and I mean you can't control that
and they just, they just take
over your house. I mean leg,
I mean I try to teach my kid to put the
Legos in the right place and the books
and the right place and I had developed
this whole system. It's bullshit.
I mean two year old is a two year old,
he doesn't care.
So I've just had to accept like I'm
going to have kids and a messy house.
It is what it is.
How the people who have kids become crazy
Germaphobes how is that even possible?
Protect
how many is a very nice guy.
Always like Towelie.
I used to see him a lot in la.
I'd always see him at a restaurant
with John Mendoza, this one restaurant.
They frequent it. Super Nice Guy.
Like couldn't be a nicer guy,
but you know he's got that. He's got
serious OCD about cleaning his hand.
Fist bump man, he stopped giving fist
bumps. Doesn't do anymore. He can't do it.
I have a buddy to met him and he
said he was just, he did the elbow.
He used to give fist bumps. He can't
shake a hand to save his life. No,
he won't shake your hand.
Well my friend was looking at his house
was went to his house is for sale and
great house is perfectly fine and he
didn't know that it was how he Mandela's
house.
He didn't know.
They didn't have any like family
pictures on the wall the because it, no.
Then he figured it out.
That was a,
that was like a glove that he would
put other big thing, but it wasn't big.
It looked like a balloon. He didn't
blow it up with his legos air. Remember?
Well he went into his closet and it was
filled with hand sanitizers like can you
whole closet fit? And they were
like, yeah, that much alcohol.
And his wife goes,
I stopped breathing for a second.
It was like I'd seen something scary.
Like I just looked at it madness.
I just woke up and then they left. They
like, thank you, thank you. Got to go.
They couldn't buy the house
from a hoarder's mentality,
except they're so focused
on the Massey side, the OCD,
and a lot of hoarding believers or not
sure. What would you do? You don't.
You just done let him live
his life, man. Jesus Christ.
You would upset him so much by trying
to change him, making him shake hands.
Just let them be, man. Oh my God,
he's fine. I mean, it's strange.
Does he ever have to
worry about him cheating?
God knew we never put his dick in
any, no way. I saw him at Caesars.
CAESARS is never going
to leave. He, I mean,
he worked the crowd like you wouldn't he?
He could always pull people from the
whole audience and he'd he these callbacks
from an hour ago, you know, and he was
just so hilarious. He was good dude.
I was a kid. I mean, I was 24 when
I saw this. I was blown away by him.
I saw how he meant Dell. Uh, let me see
them, a bunch of his different specials,
but I had one that I was passing around
a bunch of my friends when I was like,
I guess I was probably like 19 or 20. I
don't think I've even started comedy yet.
And how he man dealt was hilarious.
It was really funny.
How do you make that decision? I'm
going to do comedy. Like what? Uh,
I got talked into it.
I had a bunch of friends that I
used to do martial arts with and uh,
make them laugh in the locker room,
stuff like that.
And then you were always funny. Not
really. I just would see funny shit.
Like most of the time I wasn't funny,
but then when I would see something funny,
it would be pretty funny. You
know, I just, you know, I had it,
when you're the type of person who's
I'm sort of anti bullshit and you, you,
you look for bullshit everywhere you go.
And when you realize that someone's
not calling this bullshit,
you almost feel obligated to, you almost
feel like you got to, Hey, what is this?
And a lot of times when you do
that, it's funny. The truth. Yeah.
And that's what I realized early on there
were certain things that I would say
that would get laughs cause they were
honest and then I would play on it and I
need, I mean I knew you from
any of course new fear factor,
but I knew you from that radio.
It was a talk radio show or a
day or when you think back on it,
what amazing cast.
It was a great Jesus Christ.
If there's anything that I've ever been
like super lucky out in this life is a
lot of things. But one of them was
news all over you. I mean that was,
I was 26 it was when it first started.
I think it was 25 or 26 maybe 27
that's the latest I need. It was, um,
yeah,
it was 1994 we show how's it too?
I had no acting experience other than
than a couple episodes of this other show
that was on Fox. Then all sudden
I'm working with Phil Hartman.
I remember sitting
there at the table read.
I mean you just keep going
through Jesus more and more.
Tierney was such a good actress.
Like you'd be doing that.
You don't even know her name.
Yeah,
she would be doing scenes and you would
forget that you're in a scene like you
go, oh you're, you're acting like, whoa.
You just get, so she was so good at it.
She was so good at it. You could just
snap it on. She liked this intense,
like a acting focus. It was
pretty shocking. So I heard you.
I always saw you on that show.
Then of course, second fear factor.
Then the man show and like, you know all
of that stuff and then I'm good dude.
I heard you one time randomly on serious.
I was driving cross country and it was a,
I think it was,
we're all dog and it was a one a year.
One of your just bits about
an old Texas oil tycoon.
Oh, Mary Nicole Smith, Anna Nicole Smith,
the funniest ice almost shit myself,
there's a couple of bandwidth,
so if you find that on Youtube,
it's on my CD.
If you find it on Youtube,
does a shit version of gold version of it.
You should learn this was
live and you were just,
you were just fucking go in with
it and you were clearly just beat.
The people in the audience were digging
it and so you just kept going more and
more and more. It was a crazy,
but it was a long, it was,
it was a good 20 minutes story
and it was the funniest. I mean,
I had never laughed so
hard. I get a car. Right.
You got to put that on that
first CD. Yeah. If you go to the,
I'm going to be dead some days.
My first CD,
it's on that one and I'm not trying
to talk to [inaudible]. It was,
it was the brutal lunch because it was
funny because it was fucking true. Yeah.
Well, my, my point was, you know,
people are like, oh, this poor guy,
he's old and he's rich and she's
going to take him for his money.
And my point was like, don't you think
he knows clearly you got I right is old.
He made $1 billion from scratch.
You know,
chances are it is a tad crafty dying
with dealt with knees and my face and I'm
fine with it. He was just having to do
all this crazy shit to him before he died.
It was fun. That was a Mitzi shore hater
man. We just, sure I hated that bit.
Mitzi shore used to tell him we stop
feeling, man. It was a funny thing.
I mean to short used to hate dudes when
I was do jokes about old men are old
creepy old men. She's woman who
wrote the comedy store. Okay.
She would never know Pauly shore's mom.
Tell me never to do those jokes.
There's that one in a bit about who have
to, she didn't like that one either.
I've found like when I would go to
pitch ain't I'll go to PJ and e and idea
about a new show or something.
And then like this one guys is like,
that's a horrible idea. Don't ever
tell anyone that idea again. Whoa.
That's always the best idea. I've found.
Like if an executive session sucks,
goats go digital and do it
cause it'll fucking kid.
I had an idea once I pitched over
the phone and the guy actually like
said, you're kidding, right? You
did. Did you waste my time with this?
And I was like, wow. All right.
I guess he didn't like my idea.
I pitched over the phone, he was like,
I go, I have this idea for a show.
It's just a silly idea,
but it's like it's a comedy and it's
about these girls that work at a bikini
pizza place in the day called pizza
sluts and at night they fight crime and
they're there.
They're super hot chicks
that are recruited by the
police force and trained to
infiltrate into areas where
other cops could never get chin.
Cause people would never believe that
these hot girls were actually seeking it.
Let's,
we're actually secret agents.
Why did they have to work at the pizza
place and then a full time job though?
Well because they have a cover and
they get to get to see them in their
underwear is the smart county
and fucking dude was mad at me.
This is chuck peace. Dude was mad
as a long time ago by the way.
And the dude was mad at me. I was like,
I think that would be a silly show.
Like you don't think they could be like
a ton of jokes and you'd get 2 million
viewers
completely over the top.
Have you ever pitched something
just to fuck with somebody? No.
Have you waste time if you do sometimes.
Yeah. Like that. Yeah. I
mean because this is not,
at first this was, I took, I mean like
I, I make my money helping people, right.
And I make my real money
is made on speeches.
Like I go to do motivational
speeches at colleges,
teaching kids to get their shit
together and stop being busy.
It's up to stop being a
whiny little bitch speech.
It's just this entitlement by college.
Kids in college is really
like me coming and I do,
but an hour speech and then a half hour
Q and a and I'll do a live podcast.
It's great. I made it for
me. That's amazing money. It
changes our family's life.
Right. So now it's like if I can do
TV, great. If I don't that's fine too.
I'd like to do it.
But like I'll have an idea.
I mean I had an idea of hoarder road trip.
I just wanted to take a bunch of
hoarders and I went to Vega taking cross
country. You make them clean
up someone else's house.
Oh that's a good idea. I think it'd
be fascinating. Cross country. Right?
At first it was a joke but then the
more I started pitching and I was like,
actually I like to actually take this
Tom.
I was just trying to piss
off the executive cause he
had sat on my pilot for a
year and so I was just mad at
him. He sat on the pilot. I did.
I've done two pilots and I didn't realize
this is, everyone's done 10 pilots.
It is what it is.
Don't worry about it.
I was devastated because my first
pilot didn't make show. Really? Yeah.
It was devastated. Devastated. I was
like, this is going to mean I really,
I put all my eggs in that basket and
I was just emotionally and I was like,
this is so important that I get this
show and by the time the network and the
production company and our,
they got done with it.
It was a shitty show and
I didn't want to do it.
And I was like praying that
it wouldn't get to pick it up.
But then when it didn't get picked up,
I got all upset and I got,
I got personal with it and I just,
I've learned now
is what it is. It's just business. It's,
it's really hard to be on a show and watch
it fall apart because too many people
have their input and they just fuck with
that. I had no input. Yeah. You know,
and it was like, my name's
on this, my company's name
is on it. And it doesn't it,
I mean,
well,
executive always think they always think
that they have a way to tweak it and to
make it better. Not Make It. Yeah. I'm
not saying I'm brilliant or anything.
I was just, I was personally
upset. I think that, you know,
the collaborative effort,
like a real true creative,
collaborative effort only works with
people who respect each other creatively.
Like people actually are proven to be
creative to in order to bring someone like
an executive into a creative meeting.
Like what are you a creative person
and you do write a lot. I mean,
you're going to have good ideas or is
this like an eagle bullshit thing here and
a lot,
what was it?
Your greasy fingerprints on this and
you're a little ingredients to the soup.
That's what a lot of it is. I mean, I'm
bad with hoarders. There's no writing.
We turn the cameras on and shit
happens. Yeah. And that's it.
It's pretty easy your show. No, I
don't, I'm, I'm just the talent on that.
How many different dudes are
Horter cleaners? We've got, well,
there's two really loud, I mean there's
a lot of people that that try to do it,
but it's like a hit show right now.
I'm still really well, you know,
I say I'm the number one trash man in the
country and he has no problem with you
doing all your other stuff or they just
don't know. I don't even on a contract,
you're not on a contract and week to week.
Whoa, that's crazy. That's got to be
annoying. And the number one guy on,
you know their number two
show. It amazes me. I'm fine.
I don't want a contract now
like it doesn't contract.
I couldn't come do this like I'm you said
it best the other day on your podcasts
you go,
I'm doing what I should be doing.
You're doing it right now and I'm there
man. My Pi Kat, I'm doing, I wrote a book,
had a great run with my book. I'm
helping a lot of families with my book.
It's called secret lives of hoarders,
so you're just happy to keep moving
the right direction and keep working.
I clean up shit for 12 bucks an hour.
I'm happy to be working, period.
Like I'm lucky to have work.
I can afford all my groceries and
my mortgage in the same month.
I'm lucky. Like that's awesome. So
I'm not, I'm not, I hope I, if I ever,
I would say if I ever get
pretentious or think I'm, um,
fancy and he kicked me in the nuts,
a job that must keep you grounded
in zillion possibilities of reality,
not necessarily your reality, but the
pony was every in this, that's the,
that's what we hang with five
decisions away because, uh,
back to winning and finished it,
that bum sitting in the yard,
I asked him how he got there and he goes,
oh, I was a stockbroker. And I was like,
get outta here. Whoa. And I'm like, he's
there, he's full of shit or this is real.
So I went with it, you know, and I was
like, what do you mean you were striking?
He goes, I was a stockbroker and a
girl broke my heart. And they go,
you're telling me you're living in this
guy's yard because a girl broke your
heart. He was willing to go
to addicted to crack too.
But the girl broke my
heart and I was like, yeah,
the crack plan of something to do with
it. Yeah. But he lived in a fucking shack.
And so I looked at the camera and I go,
I guess we are all released five decisions
away from shitting in a bucket. Yeah.
Wow. And, and that just stuck.
And when I said that people ran with
it and I'm clearly five had many five
decisions away from shitting in a
bucket and mean couple things different
happened.
And I in my life could have been told
it might not be any five,
it can be one if it's a bad one,
peed in mountain dew cans.
So I car skip the eggs.
I missed once and I was trying
to get my dick into the whole.
But of course I have a very fat head,
very dominate your whole is huge.
And the amount of the whole of
it wasn't a mountain do actually.
It was a Pepsi bottle.
And I was trying to try to get it in
there and I fucking spray cause I was kind
of holding it back and then I
sprayed it all over my fucking pants.
I pissed all over my leg dude before
I finally got it going in the bottle.
So this is only a year ago by the way.
I shit myself the first year
driving. No, it was a year ago.
I didn't tell you about this.
I fucking shit myself.
The other day I did one of those parts
where I'm working and it just went like
that and I thought it felt like a fart.
And then I reached down and just to like
itch my ass and it was really wet and
creamy and I pull it out, baby diaper
shit all over my pants. I'm like,
wait a minute,
you must falling down to claw at your ass.
Like I went to itch my asshole
asshole
asshole on a regular basis and then
just go around and touch through,
smell out of your mouth.
So it's never itch from the inside.
I never touched your fucking
door again. No, no, no.
I'm not talking like I went to like
deep in my asshole like I was talking to
like right above my ass. It's creamy
shit. All creepy shit everywhere.
I don't believe you just dabble
over the top. I think he goes by.
No I don't. Why would I do
that? That's disgusting.
But it was so bad and I didn't
even know. Wow. You gotta Numb Ass.
You've got a problem. Do you think it's
mostly getting raped by ghosts? No.
But do you think when this shit happens,
do you,
do you think it's because like you're
trying to force a fart out so bad.
He's like,
if I just don't,
I try to force Fartah I tried to
make them loud as possible and fast.
Oh awesome.
I had a thing about this.
I always say like when mode nine out of
10 times your asshole, it has your back,
right? He'll back you up. They
didn't say no, it's a fart.
You know the last second that shit and
it catches it. Right. And I was like,
I wish your asshole would do that. Like
in other parts of your life. Right.
You know, like when you're going to fuck
the fat girl at three o'clock, right?
You're assholes. Like, Hey,
hang on a second buddy. Wait,
your asshole kid,
hold back the liquid.
That's what I find when it's liquid and
you feel that, oh, it's coming too fast.
You know your asshole sends alarms
up. Yeah. This was liquid. This, yeah.
Yeah.
It's your diet probably,
but it's, that's the first time in
three years maybe that's happened
since I've been drinking these
Kale shakes on a regular basis.
It never had kale shakes.
You know what the hell by itself
will fuck it and just destroy you.
It's really good for you. Oh, I
know. Yeah. Um, there's a Vitamix.
I throw two cumbers Kale, celery, um, uh,
one pair, a big chunk of ginger
and four or five cloves of garlic.
I mean,
you're going to lose five pounds a day
of shit to clean up stomach weight,
but you feel great. You do? Yeah.
Oh Man. This feels like I'm saying,
I've been talking to him and tell about
it helped me out with shakes and stuff
to try and get healthy. I'm talking
about Kevin James turned me onto it.
He lost 80 pounds and uh,
he was explaining to me in
his book that he bought a,
he had this lady working form
as a chef for a while and uh,
the idea was it was the,
there's like really nutrient rich plant
based foods blended up together that
would be like your first meal
a day and just doing that,
it keeps like your digestive track,
like really sweet because
it essentially like,
it's like it's a flush out and like cleans
out already is a very important thing.
I don't realize. Yeah.
Well yeah, I mean it's,
you're not supposed to be keeping shit
inside your body. You know, you can,
if you have a bad diet,
I,
my job probably half of my job is looking
at what comes out of a person that
doesn't eat healthfully.
That's a fetish of yourself.
I think I'm starting to
think part of my life.
I think it's just what it
is is a part of my life man.
And there's in your ass well separate.
I just liked it.
I just like a finger in my ass that has
nothing to do with porn. No. I like,
um,
I probably shouldn't go into that.
Okay.
I'm with you. I don't, I don't
and they don't like it. Andy.
I don't like a skinny girl.
I liked them.
Wait, I'm the girl. That's all I'm saying.
The fatter ones are loosely more fun.
It's stream, mate. That's what I do.
Bbws you just go through the
top 10 and it's beautiful.
10 pounds heavy is way better than
10 pounds to light. Well, I'm talking
about, I'm talking about it. Oh yeah.
But I agree with that. What does BBW big,
beautiful women. Oh, cheers. Cheers.
Yeah. Women don't understand that little
fat as sexy. It doesn't bother me at all.
You know,
as long as you know the unhealthy little
oils don't look that good naked. No, no.
They don't want and it looks beautiful.
It's more skin to play with.
It feels like you're on a,
would you rather have a king
size pool or a little baby pool?
This is a horrible topic,
but to bring it up. No,
you're just talking to Brian and that's
what brought my a great topic. My, my,
my wife and I had, uh, my wife's
really big into natural birth.
We had a natural birth funny guys.
Yeah. We know what it was awesome.
And most people do. It's fine. We
actually had it in our bedroom at home.
It was amazing. Um, most
people think it's crazy.
My wife like that was her iron man.
Like she really wanted that.
She did it yesterday and it was
really cool and I, and I dug it. Wow.
The subsequent argument was do
you circumcise a kid or not?
Because all of her natural war and it's
really hippie world and I'm not into the
whole hippiness of the world.
I enjoyed the process of natural birth,
but I'm not into the whole hippie
lifestyle part of it. Right.
And all of her friends, they didn't
circumstance or kids and I was like,
I'm not about to send my kid
to gym class in a very, uh,
a world where everyone gets
circumcised to pink song. Yeah.
I think that's changing.
It used to be apparently is 50 50 now.
I wouldn't circumcise a kid if I had a
boy. Wouldn't circle. Well apparently,
but the point that conversation was we,
the girls are all the wives start arguing.
We start talking three of the wall.
I was guaranteed they were like sex
with a dude that is not circumcised is
substantially better than a dude that is,
and then all these girls were like, oh,
that's true. That's true. That's
why I don't know. More scan.
Apparently back to the,
just like we talked about the ladies
and they all were like absolutely.
Like it wasn't like they were
being nice for the woman. Wow.
I've never even heard that before I
buy it. I was like, wow, I got robbed.
Even with licensed,
even if I wasn't serving size I don't
think would make a difference me,
but I think it's a fucking
gross tradition, man.
Somebody said the cure, it's,
it helps prevent aids. I'm like, well
you keep an aids and you're forced skin.
Like what's going on? How has that, I know
that seems to me the exposure to aids
and lack of exposure is how you prevent
aids.
Not like for skin chopping off
purely cosmetic for us and I,
but I enforced, I was like,
we're absolutely doing it.
We're not going to have one kid that
is and when candidate isn't consistent,
Jesus Christ. I mean, why does, my brother
looked different than me. You know,
I like to fuck Jewish weddings, so I'm
definitely, yeah, circumcised. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. Whatever you like freak
Jewish women. I think it's just session.
So weird fucking tradition that we need
to end your cutting and not only that,
but people get like really bad infections.
It's not,
it's not completely innocuous.
Kids have lost their penises because of,
because of circumcisions.
It's not,
my nephew had to go back for a
second and operation because of that.
I don't put them under the age of
a year or something. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Yeah. Mad for
what? To dress up. Nice.
We should start some kind of tick.
It's not a jack-o-lantern. Right.
He'd have to chop parts off of it to
make it look better. That's stupid.
Save the peanuts,
peanuts in a jar and where it has a neck,
what kind of tests have actually been
done that show that there's some sort of a
health benefit to circumcision there?
There've been any, there has to be
a Christian school.
Probably did the research really.
I'm sure it's, I'm sure it's a metal.
There's a, I mean it costs four grand.
I'll tell you that.
That's how much you gonna pay.
You didn't have like an old Jewish dude
suck the blood off of it afterwards too.
John have a breast now.
Isn't that amazing that,
that they actually still do
it that way some places. Yeah.
A guy will suck the blood off and you
know, and he was explaining it on,
on a youtube video and it was
like a serious, you know, um, uh,
you know,
what does the Word Orthodox Jew and he
was saying that it's an ancient tradition
because of the blood. Uh, actually, uh,
coagulates better because of the saliva.
It stops the bleeding quicker. I
just spit on that penis ever. Man.
That's where I go back to. Wouldn't have
that on my kid. But if that's your thing,
that's your thing, I support
you. Right. Decrease in fit.
Here's one of the problems.
One of the benefits decrease in physical
problems involving a tight foreskin. Uh,
yeah. That means because you got no
force, can you fuck, that's the dumbest.
That's the dumbest benefit I've ever had.
And that's the red rather
than that's the first benefit.
They listed benefits increasing physical
problems involving a tight for skin.
Well you knew a lot of kids are running
around complaining about tight forced
cans. Isn't it more susceptible
to disease because there's,
it's like you're having that extra belly
button on your Dick it, well, I would,
yeah, I dunno. I mean shit, it's got
to get dirty or you mean when it's,
when there is, there is tickling. I've
been told what's it taste like? Well,
I think it's also like moist. I think that
to the head of the penis, I don't need,
the four skin is moist
and much more sensitive.
When you circumcised that it dries out.
It's like half numb.
It's gotta be moldy every time.
And lower incidents of the inflammation
of the head of the penis, whatever,
urinate, reduced urinary tract infections
because it kind of makes sense. Clean.
You're dirty Dick. I can fix all
that. Fewer problems with erections,
especially at puberty. Why is there a
problem with an erection? Why? Yeah,
that doesn't mean never been a problem
in my life. If you were problems,
it looks creepy. What does that mean
by problems? You know what that means?
That means he's getting erections all
the time because I've heard that happens
to people that are circumcised.
Like when you pull the skin back,
like they get excited like really easily.
Apparently it doesn't have,
it's much more sensitive and if
the wind blows, that's funny.
That's a listed as a benefit.
Fewer problems with erections,
especially at puberty. When you
write, especially a puberty,
I'm assuming you don't want kids to
fuck at 13 so I'm thinking you're saying
these are unwanted directions, so some
old, some old woman or old dude, right,
but so they're saying we've made your
penis feel less good so you don't have as
many problems with it. Feeling good. Back
to my point of these women were saying,
apparently it feels better,
decrease in certain sexual transmitted
sexually transmitted diseases such as
HIV, HPV, genital herpes,
syphilis and other microorganisms in
men and their partners. A decrease. Hmm.
Okay. Well, I don't know. Yeah. Why
is that? Does that resemble more skin?
How do you know there's more, there's
more shit holes and peace books on. Yeah.
Well almost complete elimination
of invasive penile cancer. Oh,
that's a good reason. Invasive
penile cancer. What's that
internal it sounds like.
No, no, no invasive.
I think it's just bad.
Decreasing your lung cancer would be
bad. Yeah, I would imagine peanut. Okay.
Have you, have you got the f like 40 year
old thing, a tube in the penis hole yet?
Like I, my dad told me and when he
turned 45 or something like that,
he had to get this done early. Your
Dick like crawls back. I get it.
It runs away from the tube and
they're trying to get it in.
My buddy was telling me that. They said
basically, and I, a lot of my buddies,
a lot of my buddies and I, we all did
a bunch of iron mans and triathlons,
draft lines and the worst,
like an iron man Dick.
Like it takes two days for your Dick to
come back out of your stomach after an
hour and like you'll never see it because
you're on a bike running and something
for like 10, 12 hours and you'd
literally like the after the iron man,
you're up against the wall and you're
just paying out of your stomach.
Like it takes a good two days if you're
addicted, come back. Oh Wow. It's a great,
it's an honor. I mean, I never did a full,
is that like really bad for your balls?
All that pressure. I've heard guys get
like numbness gets really bad blisters.
You got to uh, use cow like cal letter,
what they put on a cow's letters.
It's like a sad that you
put on your balls, you know,
get rid of that ball so you don't get
any, get really bad blisters. Yeah. Jesus.
Hey Brian,
pull up a youtube video.
Rabbi explains the process
of sucking blood from penis.
That's it's on youtube. It's a bit
aggressive, I think. Yeah. What the fuck?
This is from 2011 too.
What's it called?
Rabbi explains the
process of sucking blood.
Just look for that on youtube and you'll
find that from penis if you want to put
from the penis.
That's the guy. Yeah. You got to
take a leak. Yeah, go ahead. Yes.
Perfect.
Four sections of, hello.
How cold the shore.
The set table in chapter
two 66 uh, I loved the
three, four, five and six.
He describes how the circumcision is
to be done. This is after the cutting.
The bone does what's called it seeps in
but seats and means to suck and it means
doing so with his mouth. I want to
say, well, why can't you use it too?
Why don't you could technically,
but it's not the customer as to why,
how it was done. Now why is it that
way? I won't say the olden days.
You didn't have to. Now
you can have. So why not?
The answers I thought about it is that
it's not as effective because the tube
does not seal as well.
It's not as pliable and furthermore,
it's not as quick and it's not as close.
You have to have a quick suction action.
You have to have more pliability. No.
So there's the theory.
Some people feel that it is,
some people feel that it's not that
the saliva of a human being has some
antiseptic qualities and it's actually
brought in the Hallock of the film that
uh,
the saliva of certain people were actually
use this curatives and so saliva is
not a bad thing. Saliva has
elements of shut this crazy ass off.
Oh Jesus Christ. This is one of the
things that's really wrong with religion.
When religion, when they
get into tradition and they
just explain what it is,
the tradition you're talking
about blowing a baby period,
that's what you're talking about.
If there's anything in your religion
that justifies blowing a baby,
your fucking crazy and sucking blood
off a baby's deck after you've cut it.
Yeah.
Only thing I could think of as like did
the other side of this is that, I mean,
my sister took,
uh,
my nephew to a doctor high in hospital,
knee.
These are doctors going to
college and they fucked it
up. How many? Like, how bad,
how many times did it,
these guys,
did they give you fuck it up too. In
fact, one of the guys do it a lot.
Someone's killed a baby recently
in the New York hospital after
contracting herpes from a controversial
circumcision ritual. Uh, the,
the [inaudible] or whatever the fuck he
calls himself, the, the rabbi, whoever it,
who does that suck the baby's Dick
after he did the circumcision and he had
herpes in his mouth and he,
he gave it to the baby and the baby died.
That's crazy. Well, you can,
this is from 2012. This is march.
This is not 88. This is March six, 2012.
It's in the Huffington Post. You can,
you can read this. And by the way, this
is not the first time this has happened.
This has happened many times in
the past. I've heard about it. Uh,
another one in 2005, there was, it says
it right here. Another one in 2005, 2004.
You look, there's, there's,
it's, it's disgusting. If you,
religion is allowing you to blow babies,
cut their dicks and then sock them,
that's not good. Period. I don't
give a fuck if it's in the tradition.
And what would you do with a d? Shut
your mouth. You're stupid tradition.
He crazy asshole. Just because something's
old doesn't mean it's good. And that's,
that's just the following, that
tradition. That is the best argument.
One of the best arguments next to like
suicide bombers and one of the best
arguments ever for your
religion being fucking crazy.
It's tradition is never a good argument
here, right? Yeah. Why do we do it?
It's the tradition. You know, I grew
up in Virginia, antiseptic properties,
you know,
what else has on a septic property.
A lot of things that if tradition in
Virginia are now missing the whole thing
while you went to the bathroom,
this guy,
he's this old rabbi talking about
blowing kids after he circumstances.
And that's why I missed it. Yeah. Thank
you. And he's talking about why, you know,
why don't we use the tube? Well, because
first of all, it's to a tradition,
it's tradition. Coming to my website and
have a gold show. It's the tradition.
What you crazy asshole and
saliva has antiseptic properties.
You know what else has
antiseptic properties ready
and aseptic you fucking cunt.
Crazy asshole.
It's actually a very good cleaner except
when you get herpes in their mouth and
then kill the baby,
nutty ass rabbi Jesus Christ.
So now what is the single,
you've seen pretty much everything a
person could possibly see inside these
houses, but there must be one day where
you showed up at work and you went,
this shit just got taken to the
next level. Everything accelerates.
It's a tie. Yes, there was,
I saw a cat actually pull
itself out of a pile of shit.
Human Shit. It like, you know,
like when you're trying to
get out of the pool and you,
this cat was pulling itself
out of a pile of shit.
I just thought that was awesome. Like it
wasn't gross. It was just, it was intense.
Um, the worst ever was, uh,
I had a cat and there's a house and a
lot of cats for people that are listening
and actually know the show. Hoarders,
her name was viola. She's a cool lady. I,
she'd become a good friend fight three
years later, but at the time she was,
she cured. Now she's dealing with
it. I don't think you're ever cured.
I'm just like with my game on,
I'm always going to have any edge.
Every once in a while she's like lived.
She lives in a clean house.
She cleaned her, we cleaned her house.
She stayed committed. She did the therapy,
her key,
her family stays with or something.
One of the key components
to recovery is it,
your family is very committed to
the recovery as well. So like her,
her kids keep her busy. Like she can't
go to goodwill if she goes to goodwill,
she'll spend, she's just like, need
a gamble at a, at a blackjack table.
She goes to goodwill.
She'll go crazy.
Have you heard of Ibogaine?
Hmm? What is that?
We had this guy in yesterday who had just
got back from an Ibogaine ceremony in
Costa Rica.
And what I began,
this is this crazy psychedelic drug that
makes you look at your, yourself from a,
a very,
uh,
what's the best way to look at
it out like a very critical,
highly critical,
honest view of your life from outside
of your emotions and your ego in there.
And it's apparently this very
informative psychedelic experience.
You can actually ask it questions.
The whole experience takes like 24 hours,
but it has a really high success rate
and curing people with all sorts of
diseases, especially, um, uh,
addictions, gambling, addictions,
drug addictions,
people that are hooked on opiates have a
rate of success. That's a different level.
I mean, I was, I don't want to ever,
I don't ever want to act
like I'm this bad ass,
but I'm saying in this massive
thing, for sure it did. Dude.
You just did it with your
will and your personality.
That's not what I, that's what I'm
saying. What I'm saying is have you, oh,
I wonder, like a really good
show would be combining. Yeah,
we're open to anything, man. Yeah. This is
the cool thing is this is a new disease.
It's not like alcoholism where
there's this like set specific way.
This is what you must do to overcome it.
How long has it been around for a while?
It's been around since,
I mean hunter and gathering.
I mean it's been around since the day one,
but it's just,
I mean our show just blew the doors off
it and people are just accepting the
fact that their aunt Gladys is actually
a hoarder. She's not just crazy.
Like we're just really still, I
mean it's actually just getting, uh,
it's now just getting classified May.
This was my second horde.
This was a great guy. I got, I got
sprayed by a skunk in this house.
I thought it was a cat and I went to pick
it up and it was a skunk in the garage
in the garage.
They were like a hundred cats and I just
stopped counting and then I get hit by,
I got hit by a skunk. Oh my
God. That was a crazy one.
We have a friend that has 11 cats
in one house, two bedroom apartment.
You think that's normal? Here's my deal
on cats. You need to have as many cats.
You can't have any more
cats than you have friends.
If you have more cats and have friends,
we've got an issue.
He has a lot of friends, then he's fine,
but okay, in a two bedroom apartment, I,
to me, that's a bit much honestly, but
if he's cool with it, he's cool. I mean,
if it doesn't mess up,
if it doesn't mess up your life,
the crossline for me is when your hoard,
whenever that hoard is whatever
you're collecting or keeping,
when it crosses over and it becomes more
important than your friends and your
family and your job, then
you got a problem. Right? It
could be. It could be. I mean,
I, I had a lot of friends in the iron
man world that I think they have issues,
man, like they're so addicted
to the race and to, to the,
to the fitness level that it's
affecting the rest of their life.
They don't have normal relationships
with anyone else in their life.
Like they're so focused on the
trapline that I think it's too much.
I think you could see that we need to be
successful. That's a tough one. I mean,
yeah, Mama Training. Those guys have
to go with you, but you don't have to.
When you could be like a hundredth,
he still finished a fucking iron man
posting like, talk cares. I'm not,
I don't want to win though. What if
they're close? They a lot of markets,
I don't give a shit about winning
and I'm going to finish her guy.
Like I'm the guy.
Like I used to hate the old guys
that played golf that were like, Oh,
I'm just happy to be outside.
I'm totally that guy now the outside,
well it's a good day. I'm fine. So the
lure of success, especially success.
Success in other parts of my life, I don't
need that success. I'm healthy. I get,
I mean I, I keep saying it
every day. I get, you know,
50 emails of people that I've helped.
They neither seen a show or read my
book or listen to a podcast. So I,
I start the morning by 9:00 AM I've
already tell myself I'm successful today.
I was good and so I'm lucky like I
don't need what you've put it all,
you've put your obsession
into a good place.
I think this is a really
good lesson for people.
My speeches is called 14 years of failure.
I failed for 14 years.
I'm just starting to get successful.
The also what your, your,
what you've done that's admirable is sort
of recognize where you were fucking up
and just stopped it. You know? That's,
that's really difficult
for a lot of people to do.
Even wrap their head around it.
Especially without going through like
some real extensive therapy and I'm old
school man. If you stop lying to
yourself, it gets a lot easier. Right.
I lied to myself for a year after year
that out. Yeah. I'm telling you right now,
people listening to stop
lying to yourself. I'm saying,
yeah, you figured that out.
A lot of people, a guy beating the fuck
out of you. Is that what it wakes you up?
And then my mom saying,
no, my mom saying no was,
I even thought I was still
unstoppable until my mom said,
you're on your own. You find a legal way
out of this. My mom said no. It was like,
oh shit, it's life's
changing. I'm on my own.
That thrill seeking charge that you
get from placing bets, you know, it's,
it's really just sort of a, a desire
to be successful. You're trying to win.
So I think it's trying to win.
It has nothing to do with gambling.
Hoarding has nothing to do with stuff.
It's about that desire.
It's about that self worth. It's about
that, that giving yourself knee, you know,
you were all so needy and, and, and
this is where I, people get tired of me.
They're like, you're looked through
some awful, you know, mentalist. I just,
I believe a mentalist.
Why we're there to meet people.
Just people think I get a little preachy
and I guess I do. Well listen, you're,
you're saying your story passionately,
absolutely is a story that
should be preached. I mean,
if there's a story that should be
preached to suck a Dick for money,
and now all of a sudden he's on TV
and he's doing great and he's, he's,
he's helping people and he's
helping inmates a, you know,
get their shit together.
That's all beautiful when it, when you
look at that in turn the TV, there it is.
And that was, it was a black cat and it
was a flat cat. He actually was on a,
it was on a box. So he's like, he was
the at 90 degree angle. There he is.
There's this gun. Oh, Jesus
Christ. Now this gun. Yeah,
he just fucking sprayed me.
Clearly. That's a while back. I'm a
little lighter. Oh my God. This is crazy.
This is crazy.
That Ha,
that whole room was six feet
higher about eight hours earlier.
Oh my God.
Another cat.
Now that these people get in
trouble with like animal protein,
animal protection called us into this
one. This was in New Mexico. And, um,
Jesus Christ,
35 she thought she had like 10 cats.
She didn't know how many she had. So
they all starve to death out there. Yeah,
most, I mean, we always say triple
it. If you think, if the person says,
I have 105 10 cats, will they have, if
they have a, say they have a hundred cats,
they have 300 cats. Like they don't
know the rates that cats can reproduce.
And so they never see the baby,
the cancer fucking and breeding.
They're like rabbits. They
feed on each other. Whoever
dies, they, it's, I mean it's,
she's riced so they're just,
babies are eating absolutely.
Whatever one, it's, it's total natural
selection. Oh my God. That whatever is,
and it's all underneath eight feet
of stuff. So you don't see it.
You don't see it. It's not a problem. This
is my very first one favorite guy ever.
This guy,
his whole yard was a junk yard yard.
It looks like John Paul Love that guy.
That bus.
So what's happening? You could see
this from space and Google. Wow.
You can see this guy's yard and it was
a deep South Alabama and the government
was after him. They wanted the
land. He moved out to the country.
To get away from the city and the city
caught up with them over 20 some years.
This was crazy. I had never, I
love this story specializes in,
I hit an effective,
never done hoarding.
I mean it never been in TV before and
so I got called on a Monday. They said,
can you come down and do this show?
So I was still cleaning houses for 12
bucks an hour and then get called down to
go do this show. And that
was, that was on a Wednesday.
So three days later I was doing
a TV show, Alabama. He's charged.
I've never been on,
that's $250 and 90 days in jail.
Just kind of hunting the dirty way. Not
Kinda hot. That girl, that's ginger.
She was very hot.
The three or four glasses of whiskey.
Ginger was her name. Let's get
crazy. She got cowboy boots on.
Hot School girl.
Actually that house man, we
took out. So cool thing that
we took out. Proud. I mean,
I think we took out like a
hundred some cars. You, the tires,
you can't get rid of it soon as possible
to get rid of tires naturally or, uh,
I mean legally how to get rid of him.
You have to send them to a shredder
and then they shred them up for like
playgrounds to like be floors.
The problem is to recycle things legally.
It's very hard in America right now.
It's very different.
The laws are so super green. No, well
the green lawn is a very difficult, um,
this guy, he was a big school bus in his
yard and I was like, Paul w we got it.
We got to get rid of these. Uh, we
got to get rid of these, this bus man.
Like what are, we can do it.
It was filled with copper.
So it was probably 10 grand
worth of copper. Wow. And
the metal was very valuable,
especially in the south. And so this
guy had, I mean that bus right there.
So it's like we got rid of
the bus and he goes, man,
last time I had sex was in that
bus. And I go, I go, Paul Women's.
The last time you had sex,
and he goes, junior, how old?
He yells to his son. His son is like
43 years old now, has like five kids.
They edited that out. They didn't. Joey,
did he have sex with a dead cat now?
He was like, you know, most quarters
are totally, I do have a flashlights.
Flush story. Can I tell it real quick?
Most orders are totally asexual.
They don't have space in their mind
force for sexuality. Feelings. Yeah.
Most of them are, haven't had
sex in 2030 years. It's not.
He's not even like sex motivates
everything I do like I believe life.
I truly believe wife revolves around
sex like deep. You dig deep enough.
Everything you do is to get laid.
I really believe that. Freud,
I do believe that.
I think every EMEA at the end of the day,
I'm trying to impress my
wife, Deb sexton. Me. Really?
Why do I work hard to make my wife happy?
Why don't we make my wife happy? Wow.
Yeah. Well, I hate that word,
but my dad always used to it.
My Dad's a big part of my life all,
he's been dead for 10 years.
He always told me he was in advertising.
He said everything is about
trying to get laid. He said,
that's all advertising is.
You just got to find out how to get laid.
I think that's certainly a desire,
but that's just because we have
a constant need to reproduce a,
we're always horny,
but I don't think it's about reproduction,
reproduction. I don't think
it goes that deep. Unintended.
Well that's for you buddy. I
think I, yeah, and I'm saying,
I'm sure there's other people that don't
believe that. Well, I know there's just,
there's a lot of other experiences in
life that are pretty fucking fascinating.
So it's just getting laid
hold on the ass jokes,
but not the back to the beginning.
You got to allow yourself to go to that
next level because a lot of people stop
at the, okay, I'm just gonna make my
wife happy and get laid. And then once,
like you said, you were
talking about your, um,
that isolation tank thing
that blew me away. Like I did.
I did about a two week thing
after right after my dad died,
I ran away to Maui and was living in
Hawaii with an ex girlfriend and that was
when I started. Okay. My mind
became open to life and I was like,
I'm post gambling or Miranda
ruin is trying to figure it out.
But I hadn't hit rock bottom yet.
No. Well I mean I had hit it.
Have you gotten beat up yet?
Yeah,
it was about five months after
my dad died right after that.
So of course that has
something to do with it.
But I was talking to my ex girlfriend and
she, and she's like, how are you doing?
I was like, I'm not good. And she
said, well you can be not good in Maui.
And I was like, good point. Yeah, she's
a great girl. Yeah, she's a good girl.
So I moved to Maui, was living with her
and I went on a week trip through Han.
I don't know if you've ever done that.
Road to Hana is the backside of Maui.
It's a dirt road and I just hiked it.
I just walked through.
Hannah and I met this family living out
in the rain forest and they were doing a
lot of, a lot of acid and a lot of stuff.
That family living in the rain forest,
there's, I mean there's a lot of
houses. It wasn't like just, just read.
What does it like, like what kind
of people are living up there?
I mean old hippies. Woody Harrelson live
up there. A Willie Nelson lived, right?
No Heraldry Hillary does. Willy Nelson
lived right up the street from Havana.
Willie Nelson lived in Hawaii. It's
kind of great. The house up there. Yeah,
he's got a great ranch up in my, probably
like balling. He's got houses all over.
He's got a suite.
It's called an [inaudible] [inaudible].
He is a figure eight the island. And he
lives on the upper side, which is country.
It's about that keratosis.
Bunch of Spanish cowboys
came there a long time ago.
So there's a big, uh, like
horse community on that,
on the higher upper side of
West Maui. Yeah, it's a mal,
he's amazing place and it's,
it's backs right up to the back,
right up to the rain forest.
Don't local behaviors. People,
they fucking hate it. They're
called Holly's, they hate
us with all our passion.
We just recently we stole that island.
I mean Americans like in of what forties
we stole that. We killed their queen.
We killed their queen solutely Dole,
the Dole Fruit company and the Americans
killed their queen to get a place to
land airplanes. Really? They
hate them. They hate white
people so bad. Passionately.
Well, they're always nice. We
stole her fucking one. Yeah.
But now you get 10 minutes off. Resort
been fucking story before too. I've,
I've met a lot of friendly Palette,
but you get a pass and a lot.
I think you're a likable guy
and you're an honest guy.
You get a pass and they
like Bj Penn. He's, yeah,
he's a whole wise when that hole, when
that, oh, I know when that whole, um,
tsunami came in. He had to Bj Penn
Cam on top of it. So everybody,
everybody was CNN. Everybody
was doing the Bj Penn. Yeah.
We were just told this by a brat. It
was crazy. Yeah. Brad has to be the guy.
I wanted to ask your opinion this year.
I'm not a huge MMA
guy. I do joy watching it
with my wife's not around.
What about when she's around and try to
make her happy hours and we watch bravo.
Bravo together. Yeah. Did it is
what it is. I gotta I gotta survive.
It is what it is. I love my wife.
She runs her life. Wow. Yeah.
That Uriah faber guy. Yeah.
I used to watch him when he
was a lot smaller. No, no.
He smaller now than he's ever been.
Really? He looks so much big. No,
he started off his career.
He fought a few fights.
I think he fought a 55 that he
dropped down to 45 won the title last,
the title of 45 to Mike Brown. Uh,
lost an attempt at it again to Brown.
That lost again to Josaih Aldo.
So it dropped down to 35 for that.
Now he is coaching 35. Well,
he's doesn't weigh one 35.
He cuts it down to one 30 so he doesn't
really fight at either. He just doubled.
It's really stupid. They
weigh in at it. I mean,
I shouldn't say that day they own,
they weigh one to four, you know,
it's usually for an hour or two,
one 50 something.
He probably weighs close to
one 50 something, you know,
when he gets into the octagon 20
pounds of water, you know, I mean,
I wouldn't say it'd be that much because
that seems like that would wear him
down, you know, because
as you, um, you know,
pounds mean more of a
percentage of body weight.
When you get to a smaller person,
you don't think it was like a big
wrestler can cut 20 pounds, no problem.
But you know, he's walking around at 220
pounds. He's cutting 20 pounds of water.
It's easy.
It makes two oh five.
There's a big difference between that and
a guy who's won 50 cutting down to one
30 there's a percentage,
the percentage of body weight.
He's a master for 20 pounds if that way.
But people do some really dangerous
shit. We've had guys black out. You know,
it's a, it's, it's a
real tricky, you know,
the more ones that are handled by great
professional gyms and do it healthily
and like, like guys like George
Saint Pierre Anderson Silva,
they cut weight but you never
see them looking scared properly.
They never look gaunt. Scary. Like
Anderson Silva. I know he gots wait,
but he never looks bad. So He's, he's
only cutting the what needs to be cut.
They've got it down to a science.
The smart guys do good ones,
but every now and then
guys will take a chance.
It's just an unfortunate and
aspect of the game. I watched a,
not a dichotomy but a TV show
about the guys that bought the UFC.
Fascinating man. Just fascinating
how they bought it from that.
It was such a circus. At one
point. I was in the old circus.
I used to work fight on circus.
No, no, no. I used to be
the post fight interviewer.
I was, I was involved in
both organizations. I was
involved in the old one. Yeah,
I did the old one from 1997 I did 97
and 98 and then I quit and then the new
company came along. They bought
it in 2001 and I started working.
Guys not put money into that. Yeah, the
Fertittas. Yeah. Frank and Lorenzo. Great.
Couldn't be better. Perfect. If
you know, we always said when,
when I was a fan back in
the day, we said, you know,
it'd be awesome if some really loked out.
Billionaire dudes just became a huge
fans of the sport and just through a
shitload of money on it. We know beauty
and that's exactly what happened.
You know,
there was one point in time while they
were financing the ultimate fighter and
putting it all together,
they were over $44 million in the hole.
$44 million that I need
from a business in the red.
That is unreal. Yeah, it's craziness.
You have to make that million phenomenal
ratings. It does. Now. It does. Well now,
now it's alive. Actually. Now the
ultimate fighter is alive on Fx,
so you get to watch the fights
as they happen, as they happen,
which is pretty bad ass. It's a new
thing that they're doing this time.
I mean, I just, I'm amazed by the
business side of it. I mean, you're,
the CEO was adversely a bad ass. I mean,
he's the more and more I hear him talk,
what's his name? He loves
it. He loves the sport.
He knows how to do it correctly. Yeah,
he did. I do it like nobody works.
Start as that guy. I do ONA a bunch and
they've just swear by that guy. I mean,
they were like just blown
away by him. Yeah, I do.
And A to every time I'm in New York,
I love those guys.
That's the best radio show.
They crack me up. Jimmy Norton.
Kenny's the funniest fucking guy. I
never, he's kind radio ever. Jim Norton.
No doubt. Wait another one
back. John is, he is who he is.
He's fine with it was totally fine
with it. If you don't like it,
who gives a shit? Who the fuck else was
joking about getting blown by training.
He's like, Jimmy, you know what I
mean? Jimmy brings it up on that.
You're a fucking idiot for knocking
one by training. Yeah, sounds awesome.
Sounds delicious. And then he somehow gets
on window and I'm like, God, this guy,
I mean, he just blows me
away. He's amazing man.
So I hopefully I'll have a
lot of listeners coming in
from my guys listening to
this one. Give me kind of the
five second pitch. Like I'm,
when I now watching the man,
I'm blown away by a man.
Like it totally blows me away.
Why is it so much better than boxing?
Because boxing is boring now.
Um, well, you know what it is. It's not
that it's better than boxing, it's just,
it's just boxing is only one aspect of
a real fight in boxing is very exciting.
You know, if you watch a good, like if,
if you Manny Pacquiao was going to fight
pretty boy Floyd or like go back in
time and watch like Tommy Hearns and
sugar ray Leonard or you know, there's,
there's some great,
finally we're growing up.
Any,
any Tyson fight when I was in high
school and closer massacre was huge,
but it was still the buzz, the
excitement and it was all paper. If you,
everybody would eat, he
didn't care. I mean I would,
we would drive to a cable place to buy
some type of chip that allowed us to
watch the Tyson fight and we,
everyone pitched in like $2 to do it.
You know, I don't know. We
know that boxing now. Well
we'll watch it again. I
still life boxing. Yeah.
You can't tell me that a fight like
Meldrick Taylor and Julio, Cesar Chavez,
like one of those fights,
like that's an exciting fight.
It's exciting and it's not the same.
You know,
when a guy can't take a guy down where
a guy can't throw kicks and it's,
it's really not the same.
But under those rules,
like in choosing to fight that way it's,
it's very fascinating to watch
like who's who's better at it,
you respect the law regardless
of the type of fight.
I just respect someone who
is very skillful at anything,
whatever skillful at boxing.
I love watching Floyd Mayweather fight
and one of the things I like watching a
fight about is how smart he is about
avoiding danger. He very rarely gets head.
He's very smart at moving.
He's very smart at it. Timing,
he's very smart defensively,
keeps his hands in the proper position.
He very rarely gets clipped and when he
does get clipped he recovers very well.
He said
he's just,
he's like real slick about the actual
art form of boxing and when you see like
him fight a guy like sugar Shane Mosley
and essentially just shut them down.
That's an amazing accomplishment.
You've got to realize how good sugar Shane
Mosley is and then you can appreciate
what you see Floyd Mayweather do. You
know, and the guy like Manny Pacquiao,
just beets, sugar, Shane Mosley senseless.
That's an incredible accomplishment.
You like,
if you know how good Shane is there,
you see like the Shane Margarito fight
when he just chewed Margarito up.
Shane Mosley is a beast. So I'm, I'm a fan
of anybody who is skillful at anything.
I don't think if that, I'm a fan of people
that are skillful gymnast, you know,
I'll watch the scene.
There's a video out here of this dude
came out last week of this butcher tearing
apart a pig in two minutes. Jesus
Christ fucking art. It's amazing.
This guy and it minutes meaning
a whole pig. It's fucking,
it's art. It's amazing. What do
you find that? It's on youtube.
It's like two minutes, two minutes.
But it's like, I was like, holy crap,
I want to be a butcher. Like I
like, you know, I was like, man,
this is beautiful for me.
Understand why I just enjoy who.
If you're good at something and you're
totally passionate about it, awesome.
I don't care what it is.
I never thought I would be in the
watching shows on cooking until I started
watching shit. This is awesome.
That I never see ever come in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He was
awesome. It was great, dude, too.
Is this the guy going to do it?
All right. He's going to shoot.
This guy is going to watch this guy do
this whole pig in two minutes now goes
ahead, but wow. It's so ruthless.
It's really crazy when you see it,
like sectioned up like that.
It doesn't look like an animal anymore.
Once it starts getting sectioned,
it just becomes like meat.
I heard him interviewed about it the
other day and he goes, I just, he goes,
I really love the art of butchering,
and I just wanted people to see it.
I really love the art of glittering Jesus
Christ and they never thought about it
that way. Oh, and like you don't realize,
I mean these knives, but they would,
you'd take your leg off
like that. Oh yeah. I mean,
he's cutting right through
meat and bone and bone. Yeah.
That's the same as your leg. Oh, Jesus
got a song. It's unreal, man. Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
How many people are completely removed
from this aspect of eating you go to?
That's why he did it.
He said he wanted people to respect what
they eat and he wanted people to see
that they're only eating good things.
It's really amazing what we've done in
a society by creating cities and having
supermarkets.
We've got completely taken the,
the gathering and hunting
out of, uh, out of our lives.
My grandparents lived in a tiny
little town way north of Denver,
but up in the middle of nowhere.
And they would only, if they,
they would hunt it or
grow it and that was it.
I bet there were healthiest fuck that he
had. I lived to like, what, 85 lb? Shit,
they worked in the farm every day. Look
at the body cavity that's left over now.
Jesus Christ. Think of the confidence
with that knife it takes to like, yeah,
he's pulling out the loin now.
This is where like tenderloin,
you know what that is?
It's the warmth of the slab of meat that
covers your spine and even like dresses
the Bacon and I just think it's amazing.
That was the tendo one that he just
pulled out right there and they slept them
the other side of it right now.
That's crazy, man. This guys,
I watched it like three times. Yeah. I
don't think I really like watching this.
It doesn't bother me.
Doesn't mean it's interesting when he
hits me on it is the confidence. Okay.
I just,
I really respect confidence of whatever
you do and this dude is confident enough
to just throw this thing around the,
we've sure knows what the fuck he's doing.
Knows every single step.
He knows what he's doing in three or
four steps and I just, I admire that.
I think it's awesome.
He set the bar for butchers.
I'll tell you that there's a lot of guys
going to need a half an hour at least a
quick wrap up hearing this motherfucker.
Just do that in two minutes
and I put it on youtube now.
He probably went to school for five years
to that, you know, or, or practice I,
you went to school for a year and then
practiced for five or 10 years to do that.
Wow. And this is so random, but I just,
I just think shit like that. It's just,
I think we're all attracted to people
that are really passionate about what they
do and really excellent at what
they do. Because, you know,
you tune into that and
you go, wow, you know,
that kind of translates into
anything you wanted to. You know,
this guy who's great at being a guitarist,
you know,
it could be great at being a butcher
or it could be great at being a chef.
You gotta be crazy. You know, if he had
that sort of same focus at that, you know,
you watch a guy who was great
at a carpentry are great
at anything. It's, it's,
it's, it's, there's something that it,
it elevates us to watch other people
would be really good at stuff. Well, yeah,
I mean, don't you do that?
Sure. I mean, you're, you're,
you're a fight or not. I mean,
I did when I was young,
I did a lot of taekwondo tournament,
so I did some kickboxing,
but it was before the UFC.
He was around and then by
the time the UFC was around,
I was already on TV and I was just trying
to make it out here and I was trying
to be a standup comedian and
I, it, it never even existed,
but I had to learn Jiu Jitsu. I had
to, because all my life I had been, uh,
involved as striking.
That's all I've ever done.
And the UFC just made me realize like,
wow, there's some shit you need to learn.
I need to learn submissions.
You had to come in. I mean,
even to both fighting into anticodon.
I mean how many,
how many you guys said you spent 10 years.
I wasn't qualified to do anything else,
man. No, I'm saying comedy. Yeah, comedy.
It wasn't mean I could have done martial
arts, could have taught martial arts,
but like regular jobs,
I had sort of chasing martial arts and
become completely obsessed and focusing
100% of all my energy
and efforts on one thing.
I have basically completely neglected
my schoolwork. Completely neglected.
Some idea of a safety net. I didn't
have a safety net. I wouldn't,
it wasn't even thinking about the
potential for failing in life. It just,
I wasn't thinking about it.
I was just trying to get excellent at
martial arts and then when I realized that
I was going to have a different sort
of a job and I was going to have a
different career, I, there
was a moment where I was like,
what am I going to do next? And then I
found comedy and it was like really quick.
It was like, boom, this is it. Well
that was my moment when I realized,
and this was after the, the rock bottom.
I mean I had a lot of, I mean I was very,
I mean I thought about killing myself.
I was very depressed and how are we
going to do if I thought about a gun,
I didn't, I drove towards Walmart
and I was to buy a gun. I was like,
what the fuck am I
doing that close? No, I don't
want to act like I bought a gun.
I did what you thought of. I thought
about it because I really got to point.
It was like, when I was going to
call this wedding off, I was like,
it would just be better if I'm gone
and no one gets hurt. And I was like,
yeah,
we'll get married.
What upset her and I didn't
want to set my mom and I just,
I got to the point where I was like some,
you know,
but then immediate it was like,
what the fuck are you thinking?
Like this is crazy. Right,
right. But there was a point
where I got so rock bottom,
I was like, okay, there's something
like this has gotta be good.
There's got to be good in this somewhere.
And so I always want to have it when I
have an audience as large as I'm going to
have here.
I just want to make sure you guys like
if you're listening and you're down his
shit, man, there's something good.
It's going to come out of this again.
My Dad dying was ended up being the best
thing that ever happened to me. Wow.
Clearly I got my shit together.
My brother got his shit together,
all of his friends got sober.
Everybody got their shit together.
My Dad did more by dying than he did
by living and my dad would love that.
I say that all that my dad would love
that I'm saying this out loud to an
audience this big. He motivated me and a
lot of people to get the shit together.
So for me, like that moment when I, and
I don't want to say it was an Aha moment,
but like when I realized
like, okay, wait a minute,
I've gone really deep now if I just
embrace it and stop hiding it and not
telling people about it,
like I should just totally tell everyone
about it and I'll do more with it.
And that was after my,
whenever it was my dad,
like we were trying to make this this
funeral that was like all like perfect and
awesome and it was fake. And
then we just like, fuck it.
We're just going to stand
up and tell the real story.
And people celebrated the real
story and mean it was an hospital.
I think they can be honest.
I think they can be awesome.
We had about 500 people that stood up
and drink beers and drink little shots of
doers and they told stories about like,
well that's great. It was awesome.
It was so great. A good group of
people around and pull that off.
It was a celebration. It was the last time
I was going to funeral. It was brutal.
Just family members crying and
everyone is depressed and whoa.
What was your fresh light
story going back? Oh,
flashline Mcnamara Norelle
comes back around. We did a, uh,
we did a very early on and he's asked
me not to tell this story anymore. Why?
We definitely say it's not an 80 house.
It's a house I did privately.
This is a bass you story at like the
Dildos when there's dildos and sex toys
involved. They don't like it. They don't
mind human shit. And finally he was 45,
but [inaudible] bundle line is still dead
cats. That's fine. Oh, wait a minute.
Does this give people pleasure in
their genitals? Not Interested.
So there's a bunch of back massagers bags.
You said this house,
this dude collected, um, it was
a, it wasn't a private home.
The family told us he was
dying of a heart disease.
So we walked into this thinking we're
cleaning the house to get hospice to be
allowed to come here.
We're fine with it.
We start cleaning the house and right
away we're seeing a lot of like paper
porn,
like old swank magazines and you know,
Shit that's got cum stains
on it. I mean, not digital.
And so we're going,
you see it physically when you see this
volume mean all of us watch a ton of
porn on,
on Internet.
But could you imagine if that was all
physical and you had just flip through
each, each magazine that you look at
and it's filled with all crusty thing.
So like,
I mean,
it was just this guy didn't get digital
yet and she just had tons and tons of
porn.
Probably no more than we look at it,
but it just was physical and we're going
to the house and then at the deeper we
got, he got more aggressive. There
were some, there was some Disney porn,
Disney characters drawn out.
Oh my God,
we found Polaroids. Oh,
like I said the other day,
like think of taking your picture
with your cell phone now of your deck.
Thank trying to do that with a Polaroid.
Wow. Like you've got to set it all up.
You got to pull the news,
your thing around. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean you've got to pull that
red button like it's not easy.
And there were some kids and kids involved
in the polar and so we were like, Ooh,
I don't know. We're going, we've got
to call the cops at the same time.
Some of my guys were in the back room,
so there's this guy knew this stuff
was there. I didn't know he was,
he obviously knew it was there,
but in his mind he had justified it
that it was okay cause he's justified.
It was okay to make it pictures of
kids probably because he was dying.
He didn't think anything wrong
with that's been in there.
He didn't think twice about it.
So same time, one of my guys stop,
finds this really big flashlight that
he thinks and he opens it up and he's
like, that looks like
a vagina. Turns it up.
Oh. Turns it upside down and a
couple of things drop, add him.
And then he realized what flashlights
and he tossed it across the room,
the flashlight and we, that was our
first introduction to the flashlight.
Wow. From some crazy hoarder
that saving his sperm in it
broadly.
I hate to say it,
we always say it probably saved him from
going out and doing something crazy,
man. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe. Hopefully he ended
up going to jail. We had to call the cops.
Yeah. He went to jail for child
porn. He did? Yeah. For three.
We got three years and then when he
got out you get, yeah, that's it.
And he got out any, uh, I mean,
all the guys on my crew had served longer
time for like selling weed and that
dude was molested boys and
got three years, she gets out,
gets out and he calls us to clean
the house again. Why? And I was like,
the house was messy and he
filled it up again in a year.
I think you guys might have cleaned
my house before and I was like,
you should still be in jail.
They do.
Child molesters cut their
flashlights in half. Oh,
he'd give up on trauma listing. I Dunno.
We tell him, we tell him to fuck off.
Like we were just not interested.
We just couldn't believe that.
He called us back and was like,
Hey, can you help me creepy as fuck.
We get some weird stuff, man. We,
and again it comes back to it.
What you see, I think, I
think life is subjective man.
Like what I see on a daily basis.
So much more intense than what
someone might else might see.
And so when I get it a hoarder, it's
just no big deal, man. It's no big deal.
But like there's,
I always say like I run me,
I run a lot of marathons and
when you are running a marathon,
there's always someone behind you.
I always say,
it doesn't matter how
bad a day you're having,
there's always someone in the race
behind you. You never going to be last.
And one day I actually got
passed by a dude with a,
he only had one leg and I had a really
bad marathon and about mile 18 where you
hit the wall. I was like,
Oh, I'm fucking dying.
And had my head down and I looked up
and this dude with one leg just fucking
hops by me.
Wow.
And I was like an artificial
leg, but he's only got one
leg and he kicked my ass.
Beat me by about 10 minutes.
How much of his leg was missing? The whole
lowest. I mean, it was way above thigh.
So that hurts. And the pain about
it is apparently it is not me.
It was way above the knee.
So he's running in pain the whole time.
And of course that means he'd be like,
well, fuck, if this guy can finish,
I better finish Jesus Christ. Let
me, for me, I always come back.
It's everything's mental.
Everything is mental. It's just,
are you going to quit before
you're willing to overtake it?
There's a lot to learn for smell.
I mean,
you shit happens and it's not your
fault. I get that. That's not mental.
But if you're ever faced with quitting,
that's up to you either quit or you don't.
But I thought quitting is good.
If a guy's beating your ass,
that's strategically stopping.
That's not cleaning.
That's a smart decision to stop.
You were beating the fuck out of me.
I'd say I'm sorry. And get out of there.
That's just smart. That is smart. Yeah,
you're right.
As long as you ain't quitting crazy guys
that waits in an alley with a baseball
bat afterwards, hey,
you mother fucker. No,
I'm going to get the big payback going
to take your ass. Kickings I'm, I'm,
I'm very important. Firmly
believe you just have to be,
if you're mentally strong,
you can get through things. And I know
it helps. Not that simple, but yeah,
you're right. It's not that
simple, but it helps. It certainly,
it's a stay committed to whatever you're
doing. It's an honorable attribute.
It's a, it's a very, uh, attractive
attribute to, it's why a,
these stories that you've told today
were so much fun. Cause uh, you know,
everybody likes to hear a story about
a guy who was falling apart and the guy
who gotten to an unimaginable
situation you're getting, you know,
a bookie is beating you up and you
owe $40,000 fee. It's craziness.
Seems craziness, but you can get
there really quick. Oh, I believe you.
But I think that's what's admirable
about it, about your story
from a bad home. All my bad days, all my,
all the bad things in my life
came by personal choices.
Like I had a great family.
Not mean nothing bad should happen to me.
I had all the chances in the world.
I just made a few bad.
Well it sounds like the college thing
going to casinos would set you off. Right.
That's what started it all.
Just really dug it. Man.
I don't think anything's wrong with
gambling and you can control it.
How far did it go?
I mean,
how long were you gambling before you
completely out of control? Years too fine.
For years. I wasn't fine. I was getting
there when I, when it helps me. Yeah.
I mean Gross,
cause I've talked to people and these
are like people who were alcoholics and
they make alcoholism sound like,
it's like you got curse by a demon and
there's some sort of full force inside
you. But no, my friend actually
said this to me. He said you,
what you don't understand is that even
when you're not using the addiction still
grow. God. Yeah, I would think about
it all the time. The addiction grows.
Absolutely.
So you feel like your addiction
is stronger now than it was when
you were even gambling? It's
grown. I think I'm coming off,
I'm addicted to new things.
Might my addiction to other
things is very strong. So,
but in your case, and I had never, Emily,
you don't have that same addiction to
Gaelic. It's not, it's not know if I,
I mean I have a feeling if
I was at a table I'd, I'd,
I'd have a real hard time not doing it.
So his, his, his explanation of it though,
which was so hard for me to wrap my
head around was that this addiction is a
disease and that the disease
is unstoppable and then
all you could do is sort of
manage your life and all your,
you're never cured.
You're always just hovering. I would
say you're always recovering. Yes,
absolutely.
I do believe that. But you can,
there's levels of that and you can,
it doesn't mean your life
has to be horrible. I mean,
anyone that's listening
and your life is Shit, man.
You can make some choices to change.
It doesn't mean it can be perfect.
Your life's never gonna be perfect.
We tell the hoarders like,
don't try to think that
your life is gonna.
All of a sudden you're going to be cured
in a year and your life's going to be
great. You've got to really
set your expectations, and if,
if for a hoarder that's had 40,000
pounds of shit in their life, literally,
if you can just keep a couple rooms clean
and actually show up and go to work,
that's success for you. You've got
to really set your expectations.
You're never going to have a perfect
easy life like you see on TV.
That's not realistic. But so for a lot
of these guys that are addicts out there,
I mean your life may not
be perfect ever again,
but it can be better than it is right
now and you've got to make some decisions
and make a plan and, and get
it set in. And it's never
easy. It doesn't take a day.
Well Dude, I didn't expect
this part of the conversation.
I thought we were just going. That's all
right. No, no, it was great. It's not,
not though it was Nora,
it was great.
I think it was a very inspirational
for people. Like I said,
people love hearing people
figuring things out.
They love that they love people.
And I think it's especially,
it's especially important rather,
um,
for you in your job because you come to
them and you come to these crazy people
with this perspective. But I understand
how this can go completely wrong.
I understand. And I have been, and
you say, yeah, you've been worse.
And that's amazing. That's
an a, that's a really a,
that's a really cool situation man.
You're the perfect guy for that job, man.
Thank you. I'm lucky he's doing
them. I got a great job, man.
This was a great conversation. It was a
lot of fun and really interesting stuff.
Huge Fan. Honored to be here.
Now you don't want to, I'm
a huge fan as well, man.
Especially now. And what is,
what is your podcast again?
I can get it five decisions away. Go on
iTunes or five decisions away.com. What a,
is it,
what category is it on a Tortilla.
There it is right there.
We are TV and entertainment.
So it turns out it's actually,
it's pretty good.
Presently. It's uh, for non iTunes
users you have for not iTunes users.
I'm not a, I'm on a Mac guy and
an apple guy. Oh, it's not. I do,
I do all this shit myself. So
no, I mean, no, I mean like,
but you don't, you know, like Max, I
just never, I never committed to it.
You've ever still hanging on? Yeah, I own
a business still. I mean, some still PC.
How many viruses to get out of five a
day for? Oh, sure. I mean, good Lord.
Do you really get a lot of fires? A
lot. Yeah. I mean, porn you get by,
you addicted to porn as well. I enjoy
it. I'm not gonna lie. I'm married.
I am married. I mean, it's a
lot easier. Yeah, we should.
We should have got your flashlight
spank wider. Could you bring one home?
Where would you get in trouble? I don't
need that. You don't need so much effort.
Which effort at, I'm two minutes in out.
I'm done. Really? I mean, I work a lot.
I need to be in bed, man. You just give me
two minutes. Thank you. My Buddy's wife,
I'm at time. Think of your
fathers. You have a buddy Wayne,
a conversation about that.
Then the night someone was like,
have you ever masturbated to your wife?
And everybody in the room was like, no,
never thought about my actual
home life. Right. Well,
someone else about your buddy's wife
always. We always, I mean, we always say,
who do you, who do you, who's your,
we call it the closer he's show up with
the clothes are on TV ads and we always
call each other's wives. The closer
real cause that you can't do it, man.
That's the close to someone else.
So you're being honest about
jerking off to each other's wives.
You're off to your wife as well.
I'm sure he does my wife's side.
But it doesn't tell you this,
you're, you're just putting
it in his face. My wife,
his wife taught, but it doesn't, I'm
not gonna. It's not gonna achievement.
If I'm thinking of my wife,
I got to have someone else.
We tried to set up your wife's,
now it's too much work. That's not,
I dunno, I'm old school. I love my wife.
I love being married. It's a good thing.
I love being a dad. It's fun. But you
know, you gotta do what you gotta do.
And I think you have a,
a,
you definitely have a certain happiness
from knowing the darkest sides of your
personality and what you're capable
of getting yourself to life.
I never thought I'd have. This is so
cool, so I would never want to fuck it up.
That's beautiful man.
Listen man,
you're a great guy and thank you very
much for coming here as a lot of fun.
I really, really appreciate it. Anytime
you ever want to come back. Well don't,
don't offer the outcome you're, you're
on. Come on, I'm operating anytime.
Come on down and you can get him.
Please follow Matt on Twitter.
It's clutter cleaner,
one word,
clutter cleaner at Twitter and
his podcast. Five decisions away.
You can get it on iTunes. You can get it
up. Five decisions away.com. Either one.
Um, and there's an APP.
There's an APP. Oh Atlanta.
The tickets are on sale
for the second show. Yes.
I am filming my DVD on April
20th like a true stoner,
cause it was four 20. I couldn't
pass it. Plus it was Atlanta.
I have been in Atlanta a long time and
I had the opportunity to play at this
place called the Tabernacle,
which is just amazing theater in Atlanta.
It's going to be me, Joey Diaz and Duncan
Trussell. The first show is sold out,
but we just released
tickets for a second show.
It's going to be a 10 30 we're filming
during bolts show so don't worry about it.
Like don't say fuck like a lot of people
got mad already have tickets to the
eight shoulders. This is bullshit. We're
filling the eight o'clock show too.
Don't worry about it. We're going to have
a great fucking time again. Joey Diaz,
Brian red bands coming. Dunkin trust
is going to be there. Little Hobo.
Will it be there as well? And I will
be releasing this on the Internet.
Louis C K style for five bucks.
The easiest way to do it.
Louis changed the game.
It's a game changer bitches.
That is the end of our four podcasts in
a row week. Brian, how are you feeling?
You want to get something to eat?
I'm starving. We get some yum, yum.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you for being the coolest fucking
audience members in the world. We,
you know,
everywhere we go,
we are constantly being told how
generous the fans of the podcast are,
how cool people are and how nice
and what a pleasure it is to wait.
Any guys in that means the world to me.
I just want to say thank you.
Thank you very much for that. Um, next
weekend I met the comedy and Magic Club.
The weekend after that I
man the Louisville Improv,
all the information is available
on Joe rogan.net and this weekend,
Friday and Saturday,
we are here at the Ice House in the annex.
It's an 85 seat room.
It shit sells out quickly and it's going
to be a lot of our friends, Joe Diaz,
Duncan Trussell, whoever's around.
We've got a lot of guys coming down,
so good times a common
you fucking freaks and a,
we won't see you until next week.
Okay, next week. Bye everybody. See Ya.